une production du studio sfr nous sans
fil dans le broadcast on parle de ce
qu'on veut nous inviter date si tu
cherches quentin avec moi dôme plantes
si vous avez votre propre podcasts et
que vous voulez la main à un autre
niveau si vous avez un projet qui mijote
dans votre pâte depuis longtemps que
vous voulez finalement exécutée on loue
le studio sf pardon ici ou est ce que on
enregistre en ce moment le sans filtre
vous avez tout l'équipement vous avez le
local vous avez nicole ou catherine qui
sont les techniciens c'est au studio sf
qui vont vous accompagner dans tout ce
processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information sur la location du studio
allait nous écrire au sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
cette semaine dans cette semaine on
reçoit des bons amis cédric et pezi qui
ayant deux qui ont tous les deux
participé expression double centrica un
temps quelques à ma droite et on va lui
dire un petit bonjour un petit merci à
nos commanditaires et on vous le redit
tout appris le podcast cette semaine et
présenté par m à points crm à point
c'est assez une plateforme québécoise
d'assurance vie en ligne vous le savez
depuis mon approche lajus que les
responsabilités s'accumulent on sait que
beaucoup de monde qui compte le podcast
qui ont des jeunes familles puis en 20
minutes sur emma points 6 heures pour
obtenir une assurance vie qui s'assure
que on touche du bois parce qu'on
souhaite pas que ça arrive à personne
mais qui s'assure que si quelque chose à
vous arrive vous laissez vos proches
dans une position favorable donc il
ressemble moins à gérer
advenant un malheur total vous pouvez
avoir un conseiller si vous voulez de
châtel qu'un conseiller pour savoir
quelle assurance prendre laquelle c'est
plus conforme à vos besoins je suis
aussi tout ça est en ligne
quoi d'autre dont les prix sont vraiment
abordables c'est ce qui qu'il est la clé
najac la hache de guerre d' emma postale
ip sont abordables si on vise un marché
à une clientèle plus jeune des gens qui
qui s'est prolongée première assurance
vie ici c'est le temps d'aller chercher
ce trio puis on sait jamais si paris
cécile dommage mais on sait jamais ce
qui peut arriver et aucun examen médical
quirky prépare votre demande 100% en
ligne à partir de votre téléphone pour
rester chez vous en pyjama pas besoin de
parler à un humain ça vous tente pas
juste besoin de faire ça c'est super
rapide sur aime à passer à
on s'inscrit et on est on est protégé on
partage nos proches en cas de malheur
et pour ceux qui sont en vidéo on va
aller voir une petite vidéo explicative
de et ma pensée et s
[Musique]
le bobcat aujourd'hui est présenté par
memscap les produits qu'il commandite
plusieurs fois en fait vous les
connaissez des produits pour votre
entretien sous la ceinture que soit
capillaires ou pour garder des bonnes
odeurs toute la journée
alors il est si le lendemain 3.0 un
rasoir qui voient autre palais dans la
douche qui va super bien
kiki mougel utilise sous la ceinture
mais j'utilise même ailleurs parce que
nice et ça va juste trop bien c'est le
droit qui veulent mieux que j'utilisais
de toute ma vie et on aussi des produits
pour garder une bonne odeur toute la
journée comme je suis un petit peu plus
tôt un lieu de raisons pour vauban
alors la traîne mais une bonne journée
de travail quoi que ce soit vous assurer
que vous restez frais à ce niveau là ça
sent bon y'a pas de soucis à avoir à ce
niveau et sinon il ya un nouveau produit
comme un script php celi vous nous en
fait si vous avez écouté le podcast avec
bob le chef savent à quel point ce tri
mais les poils de narines c'est
important est bien indiquée pour sortir
le oui doit que kiel l'instrument ultime
oserais-je dire pour trimer les narines
moi je l'utilisé jeu les packs - 6 mai
j'ai utilisé à l'appartement puis ça
marche ça fait ça fait des miracles fait
c'est magique puis si vous voulez si
vous avez déjà le lendemain on proposera
vous voulez essayer le wind waker vous
allez adorer se susurre on a un code
promo pour vous qui est sans filtre en
un mot pour 20% de rabais et le shipping
gratuit donc sauté la tue vous n'avez
pas le regretter
nous entrons le podcast aujourd'hui est
présenté par aïda science qui est une
entreprise de recherche contractuelle
spécialisée dans les essais cliniques a
été fondée en 9 92
ici au québec lors le coup sont à
montréal puisqu'ils font en fait qui
soutiennent la commercialisation de
médicaments génériques donc des copies
ou des versions moins chères mais tout
aussi efficace des médicaments que vous
connaissez bien qu'ils sont déjà sur le
marché
y participent aussi à mettre sur le
marché des nouveaux médicaments dont
c'est la recherche en science la
recherche clinique c'est super important
snetap
essentiel en fait au développement de
nouveaux médicaments pis ces médicaments
la presse au on en a besoin et donc un
serment important de participer il est
de soutenir la recherche
comment ça fonctionne en fait c'est que
vous allez aller sur leur site web où
les appeler pour l'éventail de tests qui
sont proposés vous choisissez celui qui
conforme à vos intérêts et si vous
répondez aux critères d'admissibilité
vous allez être choisi pour aller passer
un séjour en clinique ou ce que vous
allez faire les tests en clinique vous
avez les repas gratuits
vous avez un dortoir vous avez
l'internet vous avez la télé hd mieux
mieux que mon appart dans le fond à
verdun puis il ya une indemnisation
monétaire 2009 mille dollars par don
tout dépendant de l'étude que vous
choisissez pour avoir plus
d'informations dirigez-vous au triple w
points gault alta point ca ou appelez au
54 3 8 052 2 0 merci la gagne d'alto
sciences de commanditer podcast nous
voici de retour après cette pause
publicitaire et oui on a reçu pezi et
fabrique c'est qu'ils sont des
meilleures amies ne puisse pas longtemps
que sont aussi des ex mais qui sont
maintenant super proches qui eux
ça faisait longtemps qu'on avait fait un
podcast vraiment plus relax et ricane
amical avec des gens juste qu'on se
prenne de bière on jase la vie on
réfléchit on on parle on parle de
nouveau un peu plus dans le personnel
puisse s par le femme si c'est des
personnes qui sont pas profondes ces
cendriers persique en mer et qui n'ont
pas peur de s'ouvrir d'aller dans ces
zones le fait que c'était sûr justesse
par le feu dont elle fait le tour des
tables sur un peu nos objectifs de vie
mais aussi de tout le chemin parcouru de
développement qu'on a fait
personnellement testé superbe au point
mort tout le temps vraiment cool puis un
autre en tentant d'en faire un truc plus
des packers comme ça plus qu'à jouer au
milieu plus relax puis quel meilleur
invités que pezi 100 briques pour vrai
pour aller ils sont bons aussi pour
surtout critiqué ce qui est une chose
qui est vraiment intéressante en tant
qu'ami parce qu'ils peuvent se dire
n'importe quoi puis vont pas moins ses
mais pour autant pour ses hôtes fait que
si vous aimez
je te déteste pas moins de mille
bouddhas wef est que si vous aimez la
coordination participer écrivait un
commentaire laissé writing partager la
discussion puis on espère pouvoir tout
le mondre faire des soirées entre amis
prochainement faites source
attention vous faites attention à vous
qui aimez vous les uns les autres
oui mon podcast 4
[Musique]
sa rolls merci d'être là c'est vraiment
dur à la conversation
sandrine était stressé j'ai un léger
trac toutes les premières expériences
que je fais que ce soit et que ça a été
mais mon audition à od que j'ai
finalement pas faire tous mes premières
émissions de télé ou la semaine passée
justement j j'ai tourné pour un film
puis j'ai pas dormi de la fin de semaine
avant mais là j'ai dormi j'étais
stressée matin la veine france a été
naturellement la dernière personne qui
venait ici que dit qu'ils étaient
vraiment stressé à le fait un pas de
casque ou de circuits sander marquis
votre ami ont bien été exceptionnel face
aux usa et à sa hauteur mais c'est
vraiment stressé en plus ne l'avait pas
de dire ce qu'il faut pas dire mais au
final a dit jamais ce qu'il faut pas
s'étonner écouté par sa couleur rouge
elle aime d'amour vous autres les amis
qui ont droit ces visites et
d'incessants on est dans la m 2 ouais
c'est sûr on est comme une caméra
j'habite chez sandrine quarts sont des
gains québec avec chiens y habitent chez
nous fait qu'on a comme la même adresse
donnée dans la même bulle on travaille
ensemble
je voulais arriver sinon vu qu'on est
seul chacun chez soi on a le droit de
tuer sa droite et habite seul taux de
revisite une personne cela explique la
raison pour laquelle vous êtes en
allégeant qui
non mais en fait depuis le début de ce
confinement le même quand on a tourné
l'année passée parce que pour les trois
l'ex coach et qui nous on était comme
considéré comme dans la même bulle
depuis le jour que je parts à montréal
j'ai toujours eu un pied à terre chez p
10 puis je suis pessimiste que the
machine ou puis de piste à montréal à
l'aca n'est ce pas six mois juste avant
qu'on se mette à tourner on est embarqué
dans quelque chose d'intéressant fait
que fout je la ramène
j'avais dit que vous voyez terme en
amande nez vous savez plus comment ta
clé où vous cherchez des questions dip
pour partir ceux des soirées de
réflexion ont fait le tour moi c'est ce
bel vite parce qu'ils en pensent
beaucoup de temps ensemble
il ya même aura que les gens tous les
jours une travailleuse savait car c'est
quoi pour céder au téléphone ça en vrai
que j'ai tu peux pour croire qu'on est
en train de se poser cette question le
est ce que vous appelez à toutes les
choses que vous parlez tous les jours a
toujours au moins une tape on y est
arrivé à quoi dans la dernière année là
c'est moi je tombais célibataires en
novembre dernier
fête paysanne été beaucoup présentent
pour moi en ce moment là qu'ils
exhibaient tomber célibataire
j'ai seulement fait que j'ai beaucoup
présentent au real ce qu'est bref on se
parle beaucoup on se met ça en plus avec
le confinement c'est quand même c'est
fait pour tout le monde mais derrière on
est juste loti on a chacun nos écouteurs
une présence qui ont tout fait ce thème
faites aux enfants mais un bon sujet
pour attendre et ce prix là on a moqué
des fois ce tortueux des mystères
j'avais certaines émissions phares
l'investir parfait on parle pas du range
à 15 minutes mais un simple oui je me
rappelle j'avais savait-il ce pays a
emmené je m'étais dit être est un gars
puis rentrer dans la vie de tesis ça va
peut-être voir et inversement
puis je dire nous allons le vus de
première main en sortant d'audit c est
la première fois que vous êtes revue
sympathique durant ma part ce que parce
que vous avez cette relation là dessus
c'est quand même c'est quand même assez
tellement difficile à comprendre
l'allaitement personnellement même si
c'est ma situation je voudrais pas être
la personne externe dans une pierre dans
ma vie je ne comprends à quel point ça
doit être quand même pas si je peux je
ne suis même pas certain si je serai
capable de vivre avec quelqu'un qui a
l'art à l'assemblée alexandrie un
allaitement
c'est vrai que ça serait abouti c'est
quand même de même si vous vous pouvez
vous rester même si c'est pas mon oncle
c'est juste ma ma personne ma référence
numéro 1 tout le temps je pense que
c'est ça aussi qui peut devenir lourd
ont même si on oublie l'histoire dext
j'ai toujours pensé à sandrine entre ben
oui c'est ça on en parlais tantôt
justement le type d'aidé lors de
priorités dans la vie c'est quelque
chose qui est qu'il faut que tu
établissent avant toute chose puis pour
quelqu'un d'accepter de draguer mais
pour l'instant pour le début notre
relation sur rim est pas toi qui est en
priorité dans ma vie mais c'est pas que
t'es pas en priorité
on a toute la liberté du monde entier
pour partir de clés bandes qu'on va
prendre a besoin de mettre un job des
chefs de priorité pour que tout le monde
peut être sur le même pied théo tard
sans rick va être hot à ma priorité que
ma soeur ma priorité que mes amis que
mon homme vous allez tout être ma
priorité à des moments différents
je pense que c'est juste plus de
comprendre ce que c'est à des moments
différents
aux 50 acceptent une personne dans ta
vie ça devient ta priorité trop menti
ouais d'accord mais tu mets ton cac 40
dans ta vie ou dans ta vie pis que vous
accordiez plus de temps à l'un et
l'autre cas cette personne là ça peut
être comme toute la province et sur qui
moi mais dans les moments importants je
vais être là pour lui mais est ce qui
m'attend quinté est ce que quand vous
êtes en couple vous avez parlé aussi
1h30 au téléphone non mais je te dirais
que ma derrière quelqu'un qui cache
cache tombe en amour c'est quelque chose
que je veux corriger dans le futur on
dirait que je tout le reste n'existe pas
malheureusement ces mêmes jo au pays
pidjot si les deux personnes qui mangent
le coup le plus à toutes les focales
sommes en relation
c'est clairement quelque chose que je
veux modifié pour le futur puis la
dernière ça a été vraiment le jamais été
j'ai décidé d aller jamais été jaloux va
me laisser la latitude que je voulais
avec pays paisible la maison comme avoue
les faits que ça porte ça prétend un
problème réellement mais si ce qu'on ne
parlait pas non plus au téléphone confie
de son côté en coupe ça va changer mais
personne n'a jamais voulu by doing la
force
ça c'est la preuve de l'amitié j'imagine
mais je peux comprendre ta position
cédric de faire un logis de sortir d'une
relation forêt là j'ai mis de côté les
affaires qui delà de l'idée de la des
priorités mettons que même si le mot
priorité de texte un mot qui qui comme
totché agents l'avaient pas ce que tu
classe des gens dans une hiérarchie dans
ta tête mais admettons que dans son
admiration petite crise au final les
gens qui sont encore là bas moi qui sont
importants pour moi je les ai laissés
tomber
pour quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui met plus
le dana mais laisser tomber mais
faites-le dit hacker paddock la
prochaine fois il faut que je garde ça
en tête un petit peu plus tôt mais c'est
dur à dire quand je tombe dedans
absolument ce que tu voudrais dire ça
fait partie ta personne lui d'ipod avec
sa blonde car il ya en copiant juste un
intense amoureux n'avaient jamais te le
reprocher tu comprends j'ai toujours
prendre la place que tu m'offres fait
que je pense que ces points sa fonction
n'est pas nécessairement sait pas ne
serait pas nécessairement mal agi je
pense il délaisse un peu ses amis pour
sa blonde
c'est un peu normal aussi affecté après
ce que nous on était amis on va être
l'hôte et qui ne délaisse pas en reste
et j'ai eu besoin de questions qui vous
êtes vraiment écoeuré du faon poser
clairement posé souvent mais ce qui est
vraiment qu'une écoute qui s'imposent
puis je m'appelle aussi pas presse s'en
va se régler pendant particules mais
maintenant tout le monde est toujours
déçu après cette question d'entendre
obligé année mais ce que vous appelez
tout les jours parler une heure et demie
de temps au téléphone vous vous
connaissiez connectez vous comprenez
mené par exient vous savez que l'autre
pense avant qu'ils pensent que vous
entendez à ce point là pour quoi que
[Rires]
mais honnêtement si le mot jeune enfant
unique
je suis tout à des sorties moi j'ai
jamais eu ça dans ma vie j'ai toujours
senti que j'étais un peu à part que je
t'es pas cap d'aller chercher ses
relations le d'inconditionnalité avec
mes amis j'ai été déçu souvent par des
situations qu avec poésie en fait c'est
avec elle j'ai découvert cette chose là
qu'il a la fraternité et l'amour
inconditionnel famille si ce qu'est
devenue ma soeur j'ai pas de comparable
parce que je n'ai jamais vécu
c'est comme si c'était devenu ma soeur
fake fake
oui comme toi avec problème avec tes
sortent d'une connexion tintin amour
inconditionnel ça se peut que tu pas
relaté s'en souvient comme je parle à
pezi mais pour en venir
mais pour être un maître c'est surtout
la question me faut me trotte dans la
tête et j'aime ce pays où j'aime papier
mais c'est sûr que ça m'est arrivé
d'avoir questionnement même dernièrement
de me dire comme ta peau bleue c'est
tout et comme parfait je me perds pas la
dame et comme tout est comme parfait
pourquoi tu que ça pourrait pas être que
l'on ne revient souvent la discussion de
comme ben oui mais quand on est en
couple le soleil sous mais je pense
qu'on a réglé ces choses là pareil dans
notre action
parce que moi je trouve que l'amour et
la mitis est tellement différent ça se
complète mais c'est différent de sens où
il ya tellement de choses sur lesquelles
vu que c'est vrai que c'est juste mon
ami je peux abandonner les choses qui me
déplaisent pastilles pas dans ma vie au
temps qui est présent il ne fait pas
partie de ma vie me dire que je me
construis mon futur dans mon futur pie
mes décisions dépendent des siennes qui
dépendent de ces réactions petit il fait
quelque chose que je peux correct je
veux que je trouve progrès que je veux
donner mon opinion
ils veulent apprendre ou pas ça va se
finir normalement affecté sa clémence à
l'instant les petites pommes avis peu
importe avec moi je pense que c'est ce
qui fait qu'on est des bons amis mais
quand couple il ya trop de choses
simples doubles il ya trop de noms je
suis là se passer beaucoup de son
pendant ton que très peu en coupe comme
c'est ta vie présente immédiate à tous
les jours il ya des choses qui tiennent
plus à coeur ou qui te rigueur plus sur
les quelques bosses souvent à tort mais
tant que nous c'est ce qu'on faisait
fait que ça a créé d'autres problèmes en
chicane sur d'autres choses qu'on
devrait même pas chicaner fait pire
l'amitié s'est donné en amitié on s'en
fout le cyclisme et ses claques en ami
tu peux plus tard tournée va tirer
dessus on ne sait si la personne veut
quelque chose fait qu'un hacker mais
l'homme je retournais chez nous puis je
penserais pas un charmant à toi puis la
prochaine fois mais ça va ça va
t'oublier
certaines relations c'est un créé le
tout ce qui se passe bien servi de suite
de tirs mais est-ce que je réfléchisse à
skis en mettant cette idée là
de deux laissez-passer de laisser tomber
les affaires est ce que c'est pas
quelque chose qu'il faudrait appliquer
un homme relations que ça mais pourquoi
on n'est pas capable de le faire moi
j'essaie mais je sais pas passivement
mais faudra absolument je le fasse tilt
sauf que c'est tellement tellement
difficile à faire mais parce que moi
aussi je pense qu'il faut qu'une
différence entre l'amour et l'amitié
sinon les jeux ça a mis tout le temps
avec tout le monde fait qu'il doive
différence en abrite comprend tout ce
que je veux dire s'ils ont agi ensemble
aux hommes ont agi en amitié oh mais si
on abandonne tout le temps après par
n'abandonne mais on met tout le temps de
l'eau dans notre vin on à mort à manille
comprendre ce que je veux dire
il faut un nom mais c'est sûr ça c'est
sûr ça serait vraiment intéressant qu'on
pense d'eux mêmes en relation qu'on
laisse vivre qu'on laisse les choses se
passent comprenez ce pas parce que c'est
la relation de cette façon le quai se
doit d'agir de même pour que tout soit
confortable mais c'est ce qu'ont fait
pareil non mais c'est comme le moi je
vais habiter à québec les habite à
montréal en coupe c'est quoi on
j'habite à québec avec nos marins ont
fait la moitié du chemin ça va faire un
moment donné on va tenir compte des
relations comme les choix de ce type de
choix de pilotes et où tu habites et des
enfants c'est sûr ça ça devient un enjeu
majeur en partant ça c'est sûr que ça
rende en balance parce que tu es après
ça de la différence la bombe l'amitié au
site ici l'amour c'est perçu comme genre
le truc intense les papilles on en a
fait son temps de latence qu'à manille
où ça s'en va et ça a donné ça finit par
devenir l'amour tout à petit ça finit
par devenir une relation de type une
personne avec qui tu décides de faire un
bout de chemin en dépit des contres de
quoi en duo le tien moi je pense très en
accord avec ces papillons ça doit
disparaître ça sent votre co le monde le
faisait marrer jamais été rose comme
jamais avec sonsun ya là bas
matignon n'a pas de papiers ahmad dix à
chaque fois qu'elle regarde andry à se
trouve dont des chansons espalem dont 20
par le trou de plus en plus beau à
chaque jour de bourges devant les
papillons intense mais c'est pas obligé
non plus de devenir une amitié je me
dise je me dis surtout pas jeudi de
compresser même temps que je me disais
quand je vous paie à jeudi chaque
personne qu'on regarde dans notre vie
nous apporte un bagage de choses démenti
ouais
talbot a invité ici pdci pour
t'accompagner 260 morts mais c'est
tellement ça paraissait tellement elle
et moi j'ai une question mais j'ai tout
droit bah oui mais c'est une
conversation pour nous c'est pas un
entrejeu vous accepteriez vous d'entrer
dans une relation de rencontrer une
fille en béton qui rendrait sans vous me
raconterez demain et vous mes amis plus
que tout au monde
vous êtes capable de dire les avec ses
outrances et probablement que
faudrait que le connaissent pas c'est
parce que je connaisse andretti fait que
mettons dans l'autre maintenant
situation je te rends compte toit puis
j'ai prononcé cette année que je
connaisse andré pis je connais même ton
la nature de votre relation
c'est plus facile d'imaginer ceci étant
dit que si tu rentres en une relation
petit connaît pas la nature intrinsèque
comme je la connais maintenant de la
relation des deux personnes tu dis aux
amis le voyons çà mau mon oeil à sticky
qui couchent pensant à moutier puis là
c'est là que ça devient vraiment au tce
dessus probablement non pas le match
était pas capable
je comprends mangera pas capable de
choisir comme c'est le cas chaque
situation ton différent tout qui sait
maintenant cette situation exacte
situation et que toi tu vois pas je
connais pas cédric tu n'es pas julien
connaît juste ça finirait par confiance
mais au début c'est comme un geste que
l'on appelait tous les jours jusqu'à le
thé est ce que tu trafiques amiens
cannes à julien pour faire genre qui
mettons pour produire et non ma blonde
et au chalet puis aborde en lice julien
confiance à se bouger de fréquenter une
fille justement québec qui avait après
d'amis de götze et puis si tu le sens
des fois quand l'ami de good stuff et
leur fils tripp dessus
magnifique essai pis le genre liste aix
pluie et avec le titre garde sa petite
tribu touareg à la haine on voit si je
fais un ami dans la main
c'est comme ça
baysse une fille j'ai déjà texte
exactement ce qu'ils viennent te
texte-là tous les messages poétiques du
christ qui s'est peu trop forcé de ça
c'est impossible de ceux du sénat mi
temps puis le catch 10e temps au delà du
gauche alouettes est en marche parce que
tu es tu prête sa golden week au 6e tour
quel genre tu pètes légaux qui n'a pas
confiance à l'antipode la ration tu as
envie d'en voir avec quelques intimes
mais le gars sur finalement en bout de
ligne ça fonctionne pas fonctionne pas
parce que tu étais pas capable de faire
à 100% confiance puis il part la
boutique c'est moi le problème est
surtout qu'ils aient un sens plus une
personne qui petit peut prendre la place
je veux dire qu'un qu'à son sens son ex
copain et moi je dis un jour ans j'y
parle comme si c'était mon body et puis
je veux rencontrer puis je veux si je
veux pas je veux pas je pourrais donner
une approbation ap easy d'hugo mais en
même temps je vous dis les grandes dans
sa vie fait moi je trouve non mais
francis si on a donné mais avant c'était
pas de chance non non ok mais super
skate et protecteur c'est comme si c'est
le fun avec m en même temps c'est
tellement dit c'est d'entrer dans ma
bulle qui quand la personne accepte
d'entrer dans tout ce je mets 10 ans et
2 mois je te plaît mais juge qu'il aime
pas fait semblant
c'est ce que je pose des questions
pichon double du budget moi je suis sûr
que je pourrai je peux être long mais
c'est juste pour le bien c'est parce
qu'au final six postes et si les palois
est dans cette situation laisse jamais
passer cinq ou céréales au début mais au
final c'est la réalité de serre c'est
comme si c'est triste comme si tu es ton
frère au final que je ne peux pas dire
et on ferait trop présent mais ces
grottes les freins sont trop présents
quand on s'écarte et l'autre commander
une personne qui prend de la place
ton énergie et convainc juste non mais
que ce soit aussi on le sait a effecté
pas la personne dans le coin qui parle
papy tu prends la place mais on en
conviendra pas c'est que c'est quoi les
questions là il ya la burqa c'est là
qu'en pratique il y avait une question
que vous avez 10 t c'est de quoi le
sabric de 16 ans très fier de ce qu'ils
diraient les skyzos qu'est-ce qui
penseraient qu'est ce qui paraît
différent de fer l'avait dit à moi il
serait très très moche pergl j'étais un
hyper généreux qui dit je t'ai pas cadel
parler une fille
simon meyer comme ça a été et est en
attente isoroy qui est l'une dès son
jeune âge il y avait un genre de film
il est vite embarqué dans le milieu
artistique en état chanteur fait que
j'ai comme goûter à ce jeu d'higuain
mais j'étais gêné j'avais pas un talent
artistique particulier tester à québec
je suis loin jeter loin de tout ça fait
que c'est sûr qu'il n'ya pas de rêve
d'un raid de savoir que j'ai fait trois
émissions de télé j'ai joué dans un film
même audi le titre car je me rappelle
des jam des couteaux divinement aille si
que ce serait autre que ce choix il a
même jamais je dois être capable min
roger la misère à parler une fille de la
misère à parler devant du monde
finalement le fil en aiguille c'est
arrivé mais c'est sûr que yi cap attrait
mais clairement le syndic de 16 ans ils
se voyaient qu'une maison des enfants
le jeu donne à partir de chips et de
bataille mais c'est ici c'est parfait
mais de ce côté là il serait déçu mais
en même temps récit commenté passer du
gars gêné parce que ça m'a jamais dit ça
me temime
mais c'était maladif le genre une film
par les jeunes et rouge tomate j'avais
des chars aux noms autant que ça a été
je pense que j tout autant que quelqu'un
peut peser
tine m'attends à 7 ans d'avoir un lignes
directrices professionnels carrière ici
de se donner la dame je me suis donné
sur ma personne moi j'ai tout donné mon
énergie que je pouvais sur genre arrêter
des jeans constamment et j'ai de fil en
aiguille je pense que haut dé a fait
c'est pas énorme mais j'étais devant je
te donne dans une bonne voie mais je
sais pas je pense que ça a été de
travailler là-dessus constamment
constamment justement j'avais soit
besoin de l'approbation du jeu tu es
beau tu es beau jeter si j'étais seul je
le croyais projet je sais pas c'est de
fil en aiguille j'ai vécu j'ai vécu une
dépression aussi qui me dit ça à terre
quand j'avais j'avais calloc'h cat bonds
sortent ensemble c'est parce que je me
dis ok j'avais su exactement j'avais 20
g photo da 28-24 j'ai fait une grosse
dépression si j'étais quelqu'un que si
jamais les petites chemises pour hommes
je mettais du gel par un mariage allait
d'abord un peu plus et un peu plus doux
ou je te suis
une fois mon entourage du monde qui
avaient de l'argent qui était un peu
flashy qui avait fait que j'aspirais
coma ce jusqu'à temps qu'ils demandent
mais je fasse cette dépression le savait
mais de mon entreprise que j'ai fermé à
24 ans puis je me disais que j'ai la vie
devant moi je peux faire ce que je veux
tu as 24 j'ai appris j'ai fait plein de
choses près c'est le cas je me suis
drainé parce que je trouvais pas ce qui
me passionne et je pense qu'andré n'a
comme seul guide en hauteur de cette
façon là bas quand je me suis relevé je
me suis relevé de la bonne phase robe se
reconstruit oui j'ai laissé faire comme
le flafla de me dire d'être quelqu'un
que je suis pauvre jeu ça être motivée
par un sentier du lac saint jean est un
gosse en ligne j'ai besoin de pas grand
chose pour être heureux mais ça m'a pris
ce moment là pour comme le réalisent
rapidement un peu de cette façon le de
sa carrure mince avance à pas de sens je
n'avais jamais entendu mais c'est bon je
vois mais c'était que le début c'est
vrai mais c'est vraiment intéressant de
cannes parce que moi je me reconnais un
peu dans ce que tu dis tu dans l'idée de
moman au secondaire je t'ai pas lieu
halloween guinée n'était pas sociale je
n'ai pas sociabilité jeunes génisses
plus antisociale que gêné mais peut-être
que j'ai suivie par georges pas
intéressé par les mois ce qu'est ce que
ce qui m'a fait sortir d'être c'est d'un
forcer à faire de la fin puis au décès
le meilleur exemple de se dédire groppi
je vais à toutes les occasions restent
quand même qu'à la blessure de quake 26
janv affaire confuse à rodez le 2 mai
ton faire un exposé devant les jeunes
wiimotion mouvement cédant moi ça c'est
le genre d'affaires qui me terrifie il
sait qu'il est est à audencia qu'ils ont
peur parce que j'ai pas le choix de le
faire fait que je me disais 1 2 3 go
puis c'était quelque chose j'avais
entendu c'est estivaux justice et de
droit steeve homsy lui disais que dans
djak h parce que je lui faisais pour des
affaires gaudin
la seule règle que j'avais pour déjà
casté que je me dis 1 2 3 go puis à
gauche fallait j'y aille parce que
j'avais pas physiquement le choix d'y
aller et la seconde que tu le fais pas
une fois mais le tout la porte plus
jamais leur fortune fait que sex-appeal
une fois que ça arrive ce qui justement
ça s'est bien passé battant je n'avais
pas de jambes vraiment fier d'avoir fait
clairement j'ai fait beaucoup de souci
dans mon parcours mais toutes étaient
des génies toi plaisir qu'est ce que la
l'apesi de saison dirai tout a pas de
vrai génie à moi je suis vraiment moi
j'veux plus réservés moi j'aime les
arrivées c'est le jeu par le métier
généralement dans un si on est dans une
soirée dans un partage ici pour moi
prend la parole le plus écouté j'ai dans
mon coin je poste je me suis plus de 16
ans tandis que 76 ans césar jeter en
gaspésie je partais de secondaire 5 pour
déménager à québec que j'allais ou cégep
sainte-foy fait que je pense qu'elle est
simple puisque j'avais dix ans d'écart
et enfin c'est ce qu'on s'était dit
juste pour moi la 16 ans de partir de la
gaspésie sont ici loin d'avoir partie de
la gaspésie pour venir à québec je
pensais jamais tôt fait je pensais
partir parce que tu fais parti tout seul
ça mes parents quand l'appartement puis
juste de savoir d'abord juste d'avoir
réussi ça j'ai pas mal certaines que la
fille de 16 ans serait fier aussi
s'impliquer sur parce que pas que c'est
difficile de partir mais c'est quand
même difficile de partir tu es ma
famille mes sentiments sur le demande
complètement divergents puis c'est
dépassé différentes étaient les gens là
bas c'est des bonnes personnes et des
bonnes valeurs mais c'est justement
complètement différent son diocèse en
fait juste d'être resté je pense qu'elle
serait fière ouest ratifiant de soi la
audi a serait surprise
crise mais je suis content de l'avoir
fait parce que je serais pas où est ce
que je suis mais après sont prises
vraiment sont prises mais tout ça parce
que j'ai rencontré aussi il ya plein
d'enfants dans ma vie qui ont changé
parce que je t'ai rencontré clairement
défini site à maîtriser 15 à 20 contre
itunes c'est ta maîtrise en santé
sécurité au travail qui demande et je
les pousse encore c'est ma personnalité
qui j'étais la personne renfermé j'étais
un peu plus joji alors que je lisais
boudjakdji dangereux puis ce que j'avais
deux là c'est vraiment important qu'ils
aient pas vraiment ce que je pense mais
ce que les autres veulent l'entendre
maintenant 200 imoca c'est quand vous
avez commencé à sortir ensemble moi
comme de trois ans après il m'a cassé un
moment donné ça l'a pris à l'après midi
pour monter en août au lac saint jean
on appris auprès d un prénom mélanie
grandjean remonte au lac saint jean
mais c'est comme un deux ans de travail
mais le moment où on estime à casser on
monte la montée au lac-saint-jean
produit au chalet familial puis j'ai
commencé à la poussée par rapport à ces
types parce que si je vous disais que je
trouvais ça patauge par l'université
elle a fini sa maîtrise je voudrais y a
quand même c'est quand même un milieu
qui j'avais peut être prospère pour elle
sa texture douce s'envoyant santé ce
qu'est le travail pour le faire je les
pousse et je les pousse et qu'on me
donne des réponses qu'elle voulait pas
me donner jusqu'à temps que de m'emmener
à macina plus raconté le mot dans le
champ la caf pour ses parents séparés
mais finalement dessous en quelque sorte
pas de se voir le processus qu'elle
avait eu de cesse depuis 16 ans qui
était québec pour stefan son université
de chicago pour finalement que je la
cause complètement qui ont des revenus
de leur allant chez la maison j'ai tout
raté
sall a pris une après midi ses piques
sur un magasin puis andré que ce ça va
casser tout de ma personne un peu je me
suis dit tout ce que tu faisais pour les
autres le sais tu es content parce que
pour faire les choses pour toi si
j'étais capable de casser ça parce que
moi même avoir joué
stc ce jour face à va être ça va être ça
ma vie je me dis finalement ces postes
ça peut dévier je peux tout réinventer
finalement je peux tu me manques moment
qui justifie ce processus l'oeil du fait
de mal et je pense que tout soulagé
maintenant le sais quoi de se souvenir
assez vive il le sait quoi le sentiment
que tu te calmes et on tue bing
d'indexer les tatas maîtrise trimestre
andré j'avais si c'est qu'on va dire
mais j'avais enlevé un poids sur mes
épaules comment tous ces thèmes plus
légers tb plus facile je faisais je
savais qu aucun plaisir de comprendre
extra-fort la plus plus que tout
approchait de la fin plus qu on puisse
plus titre après l'arrêt plus détestés
cij et angoissé mais je vais déjà pas
travailler là dedans fait c'est juste
piste est moins stressant parce que
j'avais cendres et qu'à côté de man tu
comprends moi je me disais vous être le
nombre de watts toute ma vie ces
inconditionnels ont six ans par la main
et fait que c'est facile puis si je
prends une mauvaise décision mais il va
être longue si près mauvaise décision je
voyais que le fait que c'était juste le
bon moment je pense enfin que les deux
là cette période le vous avez l'espèce
de déclic de faut que j'arrête d'être la
personne que les autres veulent que ce
choix faut que je sois la personne aimée
kitsch et c'est que moi je dois être là
c'est pour ça aussi être un petit 6 y
mettons une réflexion un peu boisée mais
si l'idée mettons des construire en même
temps pts / construire ensemble un conte
mettons le thé en soutenant péan ces
dames et ça fait un building qui est pas
mal à coller le petit fils a assez parlé
ensuite on va construire des tours
jumelles mars
vous avez toujours non non non non non
et non
non mais j'ai jamais jamais sûr je ne
sais pas encore monovolume elle en fait
j'ai accepté en fait nous cette année
est vraiment dans l'acceptance le mais
j'ai accepté que jal est jamais savoir
qu'est-ce pas grave vu que je suis une
personne de même je vais prendre ce qui
va venir et puis je m'assurer d'être
bien d'étudier dans ce que je fais ce
qui est difficile c'est quand tu es pris
dans un dans une dans une roue dans une
carrière surtout le cinematic anti
travers matin tu te dis si j'aime pas ta
en soule j'ai tout le temps un pardessus
et dont seul cette idée leur mais j'ai
eu le déclic dernièrement que met-on
penser au futur la seule fait la seule
raison que j'aurai de penser trop au
futur pied une stabilité
c'est l'idée de fonder une famille
méthon ça c'est la seule raison qu'ils
feraient que je dois penser à mes
actions en vue de ce qui s'en vient
c'est mon internat circulent surtout
monothérapie stabilité d'emploi petit le
quitte
puisse ce une fois que j'ai compris que
c'était la seule piste à cette action
qu'on avait par rapport à ce que j'ai
compris que c'était la seule raison
pourquoi chanter le genre de pression de
me placer de savoir qu'est ce que je
ferais d'avant revenu constant et cetera
et cetera et cetera une fois j'ai
réalisé ce puits que j'ai faite
l'adéquation entre fiq potentiellement
que j en veux pas nécessairement
d'enfant puis de famille et ses tipis
sujet fait non je pense j'ai jamais
était certaine
puis je me suis dit sachant ce que c'est
pas une nécessité pour moi mettons
d'avoir une famille d'avoir une maison
qui intéresse tout ce puits que c'était
la seule raison pour laquelle je me
mettait la pression à savoir qu'est ce
que je dois faire de même atteint 20
crise une fois que j'ai fait c'est ce
lien là j'en ai plus vraiment une
pression à me dire ça me prenne
stabilité puis cette réflexion l'homme a
amené un genre de sentiment d'être en
bonne place même si je sais pas
exactement
où ça sans vote s'est senti tout le
temps que j'aime foule était en bonne
place
c'est que tu peux pas être ailleurs
qu'ici c'est là c'est la chose peut
paraître ailleurs qu'ici tu peux pas y a
pas d'autres timeline que celle qu'on ne
leur porte
il ya une phrase qu'on a eu dernièrement
david goudreault ça fait deux fois je le
dis parce que c'est la meilleure chose
de l'histoire ok c'est un auteur on leur
super casse puis quand les gens vont
attendre ils vont sûrement l'avoir déjà
entendu on peut importe on va je vais
déjà sport et lille mais dit citant un
bilan a passé puis un pied dans le futur
tête en bonne position pour chier sur le
présent c'est tellement fort que j'ai
jamais su qu est ce que je le frappe
mais le ménage etc on trouve une peine
dans l'idée que je suis obligé le savons
non c'est ouais toutes et tous les frais
en terme de terme sportif la télé poussé
sur le plus loin possible mais après ça
ça n'a volé déclaré qu est-ce que
l'espace est entré avec 0 c'est la
seconde que ce c'est fini tu le sais on
est parti en taiwan ensemble la seconde
que je suis parti en taïwan avec toi si
t'es l'infini là après le plus loin
encore mais je dois y avait plus rien et
je n'ai finalement carlos porter seule
chose qui me c'était la seule chose qui
me qui miment dictait ma direction
le matraquage malbaie mon seul objectif
de celui là mais je pense le sport
autant que ça peut être vraiment
bénéfique pour la vie en général on en
parlais tantôt en autant que ça peut
être parce que moi j'ai fait la même si
le même parfum que j'ai joué au hockey
jusqu'à 20 antichambre junior majeur
puis avant surgit jamais pensé à qu'est
ce que j'allais faire tous existe si
tout ce qui existait dans ma vie c'était
7 7 jours sur 7 morts qui c'était ma
ville de la journée de souvenir en quête
d attapeu
si je vais enfin c'est fou parce qu'ils
avaient deux minutes déjà aux phoques
c'est quelque chose que de plusieurs
minutes déjà phoque
j'ai tout mis là dedans j'ai tout mis
mes énergies je voyais que ce je pensais
qu après je pense à rien d'autre que ça
s'arrête puis comme la raison plaquettes
août à lever le matin elles existent
plus la raison pour l'appui en plus par
quoi tu te définis si oui comment des ph
qui est une envie vous et moi je fais de
la natation on entendrait que je veux
dire me jour là la journée ou est ce que
t'as qu'a permis quelqu'un dit pitois
que ce fait j'ai joué j'ai joué à angers
personne n'y a personne qui joue à un
classement des jeux transparaître de
cinq ans d'acquis et h natation de seppi
moi j'ai arrêté parce qu'on leur fasse
arrêter à 117 près ce que j'ai fait ma
vie dans un autre domaine mai mais moins
c'est ce qu'ils doivent s'y plier rien
d'autre mais par exemple avec le temps
ce que moi ce que je me suis rendu
compte c'est que j'étais capable de
transférer l'énergie pléthorique j'avais
dans le sport dans quelques analyses
dans l'autre chose c'est finalement
puisque j'ai appris dans la coke
analyser ma tendresse et ça et moi dans
le fond ce que j'ai fait c'est qui j'ai
arrêté le sport puis je l'utilisé en
musique je fait à 180° complètement mais
la musique c'est que c'est quand même
même si un autre espace est en or il ya
beaucoup de choses qui le similarités
c'est l'artiste parce que si tu mettais
berline focus à travailler ton truc à
pratiquer en laissant traîner l'autre
s'appelle presse qui met sa même affaire
au pis c'est la discipline que toi qui
va faire que votre ventre loin sur tech
moi j'ai comme juste pas nié ce geste
arrivé petit bijou est de tarbes et la
guitare au cégep y jeter loin d'être les
meilleurs mais rapidement mes profs ils
m'ont dit pour sa part est une
discipline c'est plus ils ont ensuite vu
pire puis mona courbe d'apprentissage
était vraiment rapide à courte que
j'avais cette spin la fac bref mais
c'est clair que quand au poste
je sais pas de quoi tu lances à 100% et
oui quand j'ai lu chez les rockets il
après ça je me demande même pas je me
suis parti une business qui était dans
le domaine du rock qui fait que ça a
duré quand même quatre ans je reste dans
le même enjeu le même mail
giron mais c'est après ces secousses a
été après sa 4 ans leur 24,1 car j'ai
fait ma dépression quand j'ai fermé ce
que le tri autant que je me dis agit
tout les choix devant au moins deux
tiges ménages pourraient acheter que je
pourrai pilotes
il s'agit pour christophe mais on se met
la pression c'est d'avoir un truc défini
des trucs à gauche puis à droite mais tu
vois tu vois ça c'est l'idée aussi
système ken block et j'ai maintenant des
menaces et mettons le studio le mois je
pourrais vivre sur ce salaire là pour le
reste de ma vie puis jusqu'à
probablement heureux le classe il
souffre est trop 5000 par année puis
sauf que l'idée de se dire mettons ça
change rien l'idée de ce film en hausse
personne à montrer leurs stats là mais
l'idée de se dire j'ai besoin de penser
à quelque chose de toujours n'ai pas
besoin puisque le niveau d'études et ça
vient aussi avec l'idée qui a pas de
responsabilité qui s'en viennent toile
mais quand tu as des motifs sans récuser
xv des enfants cette pression là de dire
moi je veux fonder une famille méthon
celle-là a peu de créer le plus de
pression que de se dire non pas la magie
de la marine pareil marc ameil à 21 ans
elle avait pas de métier il avait tout
comprendre un mot des risques financiers
aujourd'hui on les jugeait je sais pas
si roche trouve maintenant le moi je
vois ma vie comme elle est maintenant
puis je ne pense pas tant que
scientifique je me dis si je veux avoir
mes donc j'avais un enfant le tu veux
vraiment organisé sur 15 sauf que je
vois je
définitivement mettre sur malouda fois
servir son échelle
c'est ça s'appelle ya plus de risques
peuvent prendre tant de risques parce
qu'il ya un autre être humain qui qui
qui qui est un jeu wii comme un chien
la voix est plus on peut lire les
fichiers d'or dans ton littman puis il
tend une chambre puis un loft c'est ce
raid plus s'il veut vraiment petit peu
donné plein d'amour mon prêt c'est juste
plus vraiment l'enfant tu vas pas
attendre d'avoir toutes les cartes à la
bonne place pour avoir ton enfant c'est
vraiment ce que tu veux non tout ce
qu'il veut peut-être sûrement raison
sauf que j'imagine que ça reste c'est
dur de pas de le voir comme ça fait tout
de même sentir une pression de devoir de
vous rassurer une sécurité à cet enfant
lors il fallait pareil le moment du vol
voire tu vas être démerdez vous donner
tout de même atteint on me donne un
enfant tu avais je m'arrangerais
l'autiste avait donné les meilleures
conditions possibles au préalable une
pression sociale
je dirais tant en scène deux mois avec
deux jobs apprenez le busage a besoin
d'un petit appartement québec tout
départ et irait qui fit et dans la
partie plus d'argent d'un point rouge
on peut plus facile mais quand j'ai
grandi mémoire ram amont expliqué son
parcours elle prie aime quand même dit
écoute cédric tu es mieux pas des mieux
d'être mieux préparés que mobilité si je
veux diriger à lebiez russe avec mon
oreille meetic entama de 10 côtes
ttec mieux d'avoir un peu plus d'argent
de côté d'abord un métier plus tard bis
mais ça 30 dans la nuit c'est quand même
sur la société est maintenant
aujourd'hui noir et si j'aurais su
changer son parcours b non parce
qu'elles changeraient pas mais elle a
tout voulu me donner ce cas elle est là
le pauvre 20 à le pot avec qui au final
le fait de faire des bons gestes mais ça
nous sommes amis ça doit être pareil
dans les mousses et demain dans même
enfin je suis pense le team dc
aujourd'hui le lap raison que je me mets
douche de ce qui est possible c'est
juste pour sûr mais ça change tout dans
ta perception de wes que tu es
aujourd'hui besoin d'une grande maison
gros serveur pour avoir un an si à 2-0
je te dis que tu es wasquehal tine qui
seraient les gorets plus de rues de
monde qui me diraient pays c'est un post
il est passé qui n'en trouve un peu
simple ou est ce qui était bizarre où
est ce que tu es et sa vie aujourd'hui
tout ce que tu as vu aujourd'hui ce que
tu as dit aujourd'hui sens de l écoute
jamais j'ai eu des triches j'étais un
bon consommateur dans vimont j'ai
consommé beaucoup à partir de ma
dépression le gibus a toujours été
ancrée un peu dans mois de des vagues
d'ennemis feeling le style je vois
partir seuls chiffres mais des vagues
d'ennemis feeling constamment que j'ai
commencé jeunes à consommer puis je sais
pas je m'en aller où ils s'étaient rendu
aujourd'hui
oui c'est ça c'est ça pis j'ai négligé
comment je pouvais filippi le pourquoi
du comment puis je t'ai toujours s'était
pas de l'alcool c'est un joueur n'était
pas un joint tj pour ce qui concerne ce
nom n'était pas consciente tatave un
problème de consommation jusqu'à
attaquer l'année passée quand est-ce que
ça a été accentuée par des sorties de
jeux méritent l'attention même salle
humain tout mais je pense que jamais un
problème encore à ce moment là puis
l'année passée où se passaient le plus
beau jour de toute ma vie que j'ai vécu
je sortais avec avec des jetons et à
l'appart puis une soirée le temps venu
en intervenant maison piper zip huit
jours sont arrivés à maisons prises et
sensible et à québec puis ils m'ont fait
une intervention qui m'ont dit comme le
sandre xâm ça vole ça marche plus le
piment ti avait tout prix les démarches
pour la désintox peas aider les
informations pile je voulais savoir à
timeo ça a été le plus le monte san
training pointe de ma ville puis c'est
là que j'ai rendu aujourd'hui c'est que
j'ai traversé seule ne peut pas être
nulle part d'autre ailleurs que lauda ma
tête je suis pour ça qu'aujourd'hui je
te rup's je suis bien plus confortable
puisque 9 2 1 il faut pas croire que ce
cri parce qu'en d'aujourd'hui
je suis bien que moi même j'ai pas
besoin de consommer le tiche prennent
bien je la déguste du gel m
je n'ai pas besoin d'en prendre plus je
peux pas croire je conduis sélectionnant
dit dans ma vie c'est déjà rappelé en
parle plus long terme
puis j'ai accepté que j'avais des trois
gaules que j'allais avons distribué
toute ma vie que j'allais être pas bien
pour certains beaux atouts du tri je
veux dire je peux même à tant pis je
file comme la crise de marbre puis j'ai
la même vie qu'hier je ne sais pas
pourquoi puis avant baisse était beau
chemin joint il faut que je prenne une
bière fouet c'était fou le stella fin
c'était je travaillais pas l'hiver je
faisais mes shows de télé puis triste et
je pense que c'est pas parler de racisme
après ce que j'avais un cocktail à ce
crime les jours la cgt
c'est bien par jour 2 monsters je
mangeais pas je prenais du vivant
antidépresseurs
ce métro g de potes quand je fume un
paquet au pech jeter ses débouchés non
salées faut du tout
aujourd'hui c'est le chu rendu même j'ai
traversé des temps pas être l'homme et
puis j'ai retrouvé mes priorités j'ai
retrouvé les gens que j'aime autour de
moi puisque c'est fou non ça c'était
l'année passée mais je rappelle j'étais
allé au spectacle de john jeu tu étais
en désintox est vraiment le plus on
m'avait dit aux annonces andré qui sera
pas le et en désintox blake en photo à
waikiki puis ça faisait longtemps qu'on
sait pas parler une zone puis après ça
après ça je m'abstiens la fois d'après
ou est ce qu'on s'est parlé et qu'on en
paie avec l'idée puis l'autre affaire
qui s'est passé correctement sur
mettront ses torts commencé à travailler
à tout les jours oui mais tout ça c'est
sûr que t-shirt ed wood et le tessin
triboulet à gimont émission de télé
rapidement avec les collabos l'émission
mais je gagnais bien ma vie de ces pour
sur une période dorée nan mais je
travaillais les p tits fait qu'à l'hiver
langue de chez nous à ruminer à
consommer fait que c'est sûr qu'il est
là quand j'ai sorti thérapie l'année
passée montpon numéro c'était juste
comme il faut je m'occupe j'avais pas
j'étais effrayée de retomber là-dedans
fait que je me suis dit je m'en fous je
m'occupe puis la vie fait tellement bien
des choses pour moi
l'entrepreneur j'ai rencontré sur mes
émissions je travaille avec lui en
construction maintenant fait de la reno
sa rive sud de montréal
puis je retombe si on avait parlé aussi
je retombais avec un des vieux en mots
que j'avais une passion pour moi la
rénovation
à force de vieillir on dirait qu'on
oublie je sais pas c'est juste mais on
oublie les choses qui ne font triper ou
d'étudier pour juste et le vivement aux
dés jetés rend d'ailleurs dans ma vie
mais tout de même code
gj recommencer solar et nous ça a été
le meilleur placement je pouvais
utiliser pour m'aider à guérir notre
c'est parce qu'ils sont nés chez vous a
rien fait mais moi je suis ben laden
même quand ça va très bien je sais j'ai
200 personnes qui se parlent d'un temps
et dans ma tête
ils s'entendent tout paul toute la game
[Musique]
on avait une conversation il mais animés
nord qui nous disait que l a exprimé en
vieillissant plus avis c'est plus un
devenait un enfant fait qu'il espèce
d'idée qu'on a extrapolé de cette
affaire le temps que prendra qu'une
période dans nos vies où est ce qu'on
sait loin de l'enfant qu'on était tous
et pour un million de raisons pour les
gens qui tantôt pour skill avis que la
vitamine l'enfant étant la personne qui
était vraiment c'est fondamentalement
lille enfants rêveurs qui pensent que
ces objectifs que ses rêves que c'est
que ces idées que ce qu'ils aiment que
ceux qui aiment pas qu'ils peuvent
façonner par le regard de l'autre parce
que l'autre virtuel plus souvent exact
le comprennent on dévie de cette
personne là pour plein de raisons qui
sont externes ou internes mais que plus
on apprend à se connaître
mais plus on revient vers le projet
puisque tu dis est un peu seul appui
coup depuis dernière mal surtout avec le
confinement le jeu mais je me suis
replongé dans plein d'affaires relatif
c'était fou je te rendre à un point
damas damas déchéance le casting dit
c'est quoi ta couleur préférée c'est
quoi ton repas préféré c'est quoi qu'est
ce que tu aimes phare qu'est ce qui te
rend heureuse n'avait pas de réponse
pour rien n'hésitons pas savoir ce que
sa couleur préférée vous sentez pas
obligé d'en avoir une
mais tous savent que même époque
questionné puis dernièrement j'ai géré
je réapprends les petits bonheurs de ma
vie tipi le jeune suisse et que ma
couleur préférée puis je me suis comme
mon repos préféré puis jeté sur le jeu
qui réapprend vraiment parce que je
pense qu'il me le dis à tous les
semaines non répond j'ai fait c'est
comme ma couleur préférée
là si je te jure je sais c'est vraiment
voir deux semaines ils vont me le dire
non mais c'est vraiment ma couleur
préférée
puis c'est vraiment content content à
mort puis l'ultime mon repos préféré
citer quoi je sais pas finalement je le
retrouve aussi les déjà nîmes où m
quand un bon déjeuner au restaurant a
toutefois je vois à québec chez pizy
l'antiquaire à dans le vieux québec
comme le montrent des jeunes et la
bohème au brunch à la rive mais j'ai des
papillons le geste fébrile mais ceux ci
sont big may cry c'est ça la vie au
final oui mais même où je te cherche
tout le temps plus tu veux plus de
femmes ou plus d'argent ou plus de
missing ce que j'ai besoin
mon petit déjeuner mettre mon chandail
voir le matin je me trouve face au bo
dans mon chandail besoin de faire les
petits bobos de m'installer dans mon
émission
ça a plus de tout ça il ya un peu les
les outils et les réseaux sociaux qui
sont qui viennent qui viennent qui ont
qui sont venus mélanger son site ici
j'irai à du s'est rendu quasiment aucun
institut ne fait pas de planète et qui
se mêle husserl du combat tout le monde
fait des du des montagnes des détails
qui dit moi j'aime pas ce jeu mais je me
dis que ce jeu va devenir être bon à
faire ça j'aime paso allait monter de
moi j'aime ça être dans le bourg ce bord
d'un feu de cheminée par l'aqmi a mis
moins de faire des randonnées dans le
bois me brûle été soufflées moggi pas
fan mais pourquoi me forcer à faire ça
car c'est ce qui traîne dit à ce moment
par les ait maintenant où j'aime ou
j'aime regarder les filles me dit dans
le fond j'ai jamais mais serein vous
faire des montagnes
je sais pas quoi tu le faisais j'ai
jamais mais non ça ne s'était jamais
mais c'est bien correct mais ce que tu
dis là c'est à recommencer dans le fond
à faire d'introspection salue marie a
tellement déchu qui qu'est ce que j'aime
et que je manque à 25 ans la question
venait de consommer quelque chose pour
comme soulever cette question le pire
était passé pour commencer par celle ci
si on ne lui parlait récemment maîtrise
ça revient à se connaître
ça revient au bonheur le sol allemand
quand tu connais qu'un petit ce que tu
veux quand ce qu'est ce que tu aimes
quand ce que c'est c'est sur le balan
d'enfants dont cinq étaient fausses et
des fois c'est quand c'est pas ben oui -
mais ce que reed pas le savoir je pense
est accepte que tu ne sais pas c'est
correct pour une gestion nécessaires à
force de situer le dit prêt le mot mon
expérience à moi à force de poser des
questions ne trouvent pas les réponses
mais à force de poser question de donner
la réponse est faite attendre et
d'agrafage ces pratiques pourraient
venir
- proche mais toi tu as besoin d'avoir
préféré quitter content d'avoir trouvé
c'est chacun tu comprends ta doit d'être
perdue sting est perdu mais s'est pas
fait mais je suis complètement perdue je
sais plus qui suis-je mais du bon c'est
ma période où j'ai perdu entre site
tout est assez bien avec tout et eric je
veux juste à angoisser alors plus ça va
pas m'aider
ouais si j'ai pas ce que je veux durant
une semaine j'ai pas bien j'ai un peu
perdu jeu mais c'est vraiment ce qu'on
ait cessé cela je sais que ça ne définit
pas m ouais ça va envoyer des messages
vocaux sous les pattes avait quand même
des podcasts le devoir
de parler un psy en podcast puis tu es
tu es là dessus consulter un psychologue
ou pas du tout non j'ai pas consulté
psychologue parce que
premièrement je pensais pas j'avais
besoin de consulter un psychologue le
titre tout part de là je vous laisse les
thérapeutes que j'ai vu en maison d
intox ça a été mon psychologue au final
ce répit je suis devenu mon propre
psychologue ou traversent pas ce que tu
as à force de lire à force d'être
questionnée à fort en tout cas moi une
personne comme ça j'ai bu plus
autodidacte j'aime pas s'en faire
diriger gm somme me diriger ce qui était
très très qui mènent nulle part souvent
lorsque
je j'ai consulté de cette façon là aussi
la thérapie ça a été ça j'ai pas fait la
totalité des 21 jours pour x raisons le
tir beaucoup de choses qui sont axées un
peu plus odieux et ces choses là que
jacques rocher - mais le concept général
de me faire suivre par un thérapeute a
été ce qui a fait ça changeait pas la
bonne mais peut-être que ça m'aurait dit
de consulter plus jeune mais quand tu
sais pas que des problèmes si sexy oui
c'est spécial de rue à tout les jours tu
as besoin de consommer tu as besoin
bah oui mais c'est pas ça maintenez le
meeddm un bon job qui met que j'avais
mon bon salaire puis mais je l'aï dans
mon entourage que je n'ai non mais moi
c'est ça mais je pense que c'est marie
luana vers celui-ci qui disait qu est l
acte est à consulter tout le temps même
quand ça va mal c'est parce que juste le
fait de parler aussi ça ça prévient le
moment où tous guéris ils fassent tout
ce faut pas attendre d'être dans le fond
décernant non pour des questions juste
après tout bien et fait que je parle à
quelqu'un d'autre vous ouvrir la route à
quelques confidences qu'ils avaient 100%
confiance que vous pouvez tout dire sans
jugement puis c'est celui ci dans le
fond c'est parce que des fois même les
parties plus proche de toi c'est une
zone 100% sans jugement c'est off prime
si ça donne ce pas ce qui est extérieur
à ta vie puis je pense un bon entourage
qui traiterait pas vraiment comme si en
salle c'est ce que ça doit être doté d
absolument seule main mettant les
soirées que j'ai passé avec vous comme
moi j'ai pas ça dans ma vie dans ces
soirées le laisser à ce sujet pensant à
ma ville etc on a des bons soit on a des
bonnes sections c
comme son meilleur ami on parle tout le
temps mais des soirées comme vous avez
ou est ce qu on s'écrit senti du boss
puis à personne qui est un qui est
protégé de la remise en question mettant
le tee pee mode des soirées que j'ai
passé avec vous que je sortais je me
suis je me sentais tellement bien gens
sortent en faisant craquer comme l'a
avancé qui vient de dire si ça fait que
c'est sûr que ce sas a mis un peu comblé
t-il eu besoin de remettre en question
tant le fond tout le temps et je pense
que si tu joues je le connais depuis
j'ai quinze années d'où il vient de son
sens tant d'une d'un des deux milieux
familial complètement différent dit
viens d'un milieu familial bio oui le
côté financier mais y est c'est plus que
cela par une légende dans le cc puis je
pense que zhuzhou qui a été l'élément
déclencheur dans ma vie et de et ensuite
dans huit pays de juste comme mn on
ressent crise de ce qu'est le monde
pendant ce temps pour ça on s'en fout
réjouissant fou bord en bord il fait ses
affaires a pris ce parce que c'est une
date du match c'est certain
s'il fallait que joker à propos de
l'opinion publique il serait jamais
rendu l'artiste keith ma sacoche qui est
aujourd'hui arrêté même après sa
première tournée se faire ramasser en se
faisant déclasser raison qu il est le
fils de papa je connais vraiment moins
que vous autres métiers j'ai
l'impression que pas le choix de faire
c'est parce que j'ai l'impression tout
les débuts de sa vie qui était le fils
de
mais malheureusement pour lui je veux
dire ça va toujours je veux dire des
meilleurs gardiens de l'histoire du
sport
il faut juste part par ses statistiques
parlent à personne tant ils allaient ses
spectateurs autour de lui je dirais
yahia accompli ans que je suis à
apporter à jo nous apporter sans vous
faire [ __ ] de foncer pythie jo c'est
un gars qui met qu'elle a à peine bis et
il n'ya pas parler de ce qu'ils pensent
puis a pas peur de ce qu'ils ressentent
du boss non plus de façon d'avoir su si
vous dirigez où il peut le dire et il
peut parler de réussite les parle déjà
toutes ces problèmes qui se posent en
cours mais ça ait watts confié après
bien des wird comprend aussi jo il m'a
permis d'être il m'a permis de m'ouvrir
il est bien tentant s'ils veulent pas
accepter normale au wat mais pas parlé
puis joe hispania données jeudi à ce
titre il tellement lourd je connais qui
tentera me poser des questions que ça me
tente pas de répondre y compris un truc
ça me tente pas assez que moment donné
je voulais pit schlechter speedway
oui mais quand cela vous débutez par les
jeudis y est c'est fait ils vont même
innova le wat qui vont peut-être même
mieux encore plus sûrement parce que je
vais être vrai bijou et moi on a tout
des problèmes au dos il m'a vraiment on
est chanceux on se dit tout le temps
mais c'est l'absence de jugement aussi
c'est son enfant c'est conditionnelle
d'accord mais c'est le jugement hiller
mais pendant la discussion le jugement
il ya six mois j'ai tu fais quelque
chose à taillis cache pas d'accord avec
mais je me trouverai campo te dis jamais
tu diminues pas en tant que personne ses
serres à ses yeux je sais exactement
mais la vague quant à voir c'est que tu
pourrais dire n'importe quoi puis va
finir en faisant rares et m
[Musique]
tu devrais dire mais pour ça il va de
regarder même si la paire à faire
l'autre si j'arrivais le cerveau presse
jiji
j'ai envie de colle c'est le blé fraikin
raison fois moins sourit john hillcoat
les quinze fois pas bien je peux appeler
john n'importe quoi briller quand tu
descendras face qui tente mais rien ne
se passe sans qu'il soit joue absolument
pas laisser kong est plus compliquée que
lui complique c'est rien ça fait bien
penser comme se le rappeler le plus
souvent par cette idée fois c'est arrivé
aussi qu'il ya des gens de l'extérieur
rende dans notre groupe pour rien une
soirée pour des moments épiques ici il
pense dans leurs têtes qu'on est un
groupe brigitte c'est qu'on ait fait qui
au final parce que on se colle tout le
temps si on se dit vraiment faire aux
faîtes des fois de l'extérieur mais
c'est parce que je laime que je l'étais
je n'ai jamais jamais au grand jamais je
vais être dans sa phase avec au final
ces idées au fake
non mais c'est parce que c'est ton ex
j'attendais juste gens de lui a trouvé
ça parce que tu nous sortons le site
notre groupe notent nos relations sont
sentis une élection qui commence pas
vrai vous en faire voir que vous êtes
r'n'b quand les piles et inaki pôle up
et vous parler de lui mais oui on parle
de lui crise on l'espère on est en
groupe on est toutes ses amies fait
qu'on veut déblatérer sur sa vie pour
quelqu'un on veut leur voix mais on va
être capable de dire ce qu'on pense puis
ou qui doivent être qu'est ce qui
devrait être fait ou jamais effectué des
fois aussi ça fait un peut pas parce que
on n'est pas habitué à voir ce genre de
relation ça fait une offre si tu veux
pas être une nouvelle personne rentre
dans le groupe tout comprendre la
dynamique de groupe oust et puis souvent
si on s'obstine
on a deux ans obtient de se ménager une
semaine au cnc sur deux
et surtout j'ai de la misère de plus en
plus j'ai une 5.61 crise à moriat
lancement ouais surtout avec le
déconfinement québec c'est comme le
piégeant qui met mais finalement ma
ville ça toujours été québec c'est le
toujours été ça a toujours été ce puits
le choucas mémorial qui est ce moi je
les fais on peut parler de ça si on veut
mais ici ah ben oui mais c'est ça mais
c'est con d odessa cette offre haut
débit
moi je veux savoir positif parce que
nous quand on est sorti le moins j'aurai
jamais recommandé à personne de mon
entourage d'aller de jamais jamais
jamais jamais parce que cache sortie
fameux pris beaucoup de temps réalisé
que je n'étais pas en train de faire
quelque chose que je triple s'est
rapidement j'ai fait du rock et au c'est
quoi qui se passe le pourquoi est ce que
comme un camp jamais qu'un maillot de
bain pourquoi est-ce que tu puis
pourquoi est ce que j'ai de la misère à
focus et pourquoi est ce que je fais
plus du tout ce que j'aimais faire c'est
à dire la littérature de l'or cela faire
lorsque je suis en train de faire ce pan
tout et puis moi rapidement j'ai jamais
dit genre de jeudi en joe cada mais au
début mon discours c'était personne
n'allait à odile c'est la pire chose en
moins qui toi quand tu es sorti tôt pas
parce que ça être dans l'aube et quand
ça maintenant j'ai plus de fun la bonne
pente johnston avec vos petits mais
globalement même quand je sortirai le je
me mettais fête d'école c'est lui avec
il vraiment à vie mais moi j'aurai
jamais dit georges toucherai jamais
d'ivoire où des mets ton team et ont
jeté un sort
après mon expérience j'aurais jamais
recommandé à personne de mon entourage
que les loteries mais mon expérience ça
ressemble plus à la tienne nuit avec lui
vivaient leur avance et tout vécu live
même et j'ai vu des secouristes et
charisme en pologne pour lui c'est
seulement quand on prend la beauté
non mais leur a évité beaucoup plus
après on s'en doutait mais dont on
hésite qu'un taux de sucre comment tu as
décidé de faire se situe parce que
cédric en parle en bien ou de parler de
l'après en bien
l'analyse du tout temps bien il m'a
parlé de od en bien de l'après en biens
de toutes les opportunités que ça lui
apporter en bien y penser dit on est une
équipe on intime
imagine si toi aussi tu le faisais les
opportunités que peut
tant pour avoir fait que nous c'est plus
dans cette optique là que j'ai décidé de
faro des pouvoirs argent puis je
l'écouté je vous dirai pas les ai pas la
première à première vague d'auditions
vous je la pousse et je la pousse et
finalement j'ai appelé et j'ai appelé je
dirais pas mais après j'ai appliqué
qu'un de la prod pour pour des coachs
france pizza est entré dans le faux avec
ils l'ont passée de suite en audition
mais était patent sur non plus puis
honnêtement je voudrais moi j'avais et
j'avais capoter la bouche avait pu le
d'études avait été désastreux par
moments on se rappelle puis si j'ai pas
vu qu'une relation amoureuse le fon non
plus avec joanie malheureusement non
mais honnêtement il ya verrier tellement
le fun même ou shorty de beaux habits
c'était jumeaux comme tu de cotiser
c'est le rêve qu'est ce que cous après
que se posait pour dettes et aussi le
rêve est pour redonner la salle je te
disais au début mon maire james et
jonathan roy tu comprends tu avec mon
geste je goûtais au compte gouttes
non merci
c'est la même chose au seuil alloresto
piété via et puis à cause de jo qui
avait dans le spectacle est dévié puis à
cause de john a tout d'un coup c'était
mon avis à pied contre saint-andré que
tout le monde regarde et sandres et que
tout le monde voulait avec sandrine a330
parce que la première vague
c'était quand même fou wifo big c'était
incroyable c'est impossible d'aller au
centre d'achat ce sens faire parler tout
le monde me parlait n'existait pas
personne ne regarde personne n'a parlé
tout le monde parle alors de lui je
verrai il y avait de la tension il se
faisait donner tout ce que je parle à ma
place ne faisait des vêtements où tout
le monde a regardé tout le monde l'aimé
en plus à ce qu'elles étaient il ya bien
paru à la télévision un pays il faut ni
en effet comment neveu du palais mais
même en plus qui était chanceux il a
bien paru fait que tout le monde l'aimé
lui au vécu leur rêve en sortant dodine
pis alors peut tirer dans le pied moi je
pense mais quand
mais will celui parce qu'ils étaient
tellement qu'on fait que tout le monde
les mêmes disent qu'il faut pas oublier
à od c'est que beaucoup de montage aussi
faites vous tout le monde l'aimait petit
monde aurait aimé quand même petit et
des fois où je disais même temps c'est
beaucoup de soirées gays beaucoup
d'alcool puisse descendre il fait
attention tu fais attention tu es quand
même dans public que nous sommes en foot
mans de montvert tennis ou qui m'aiment
et paris je peux être moi même accueil
au japon et mets moi-même je peux me
laisser aller puiser sans riz qui ont vu
le parti doit et aimerait pas
il m'est fait attention ça tire dans le
pied parce qu'ils avaient des soirées ou
mais au final tout petits pour revenir à
aujourd'hui et au final ce steve ross
skeate arriverait à moi la presse us
theron parce que au final c'est parce
que je voulais maintenant je leur tricot
finale parce que je voulais mais mais je
ne serai pas mais je préfère ne pas y
aller je le vis
mais c'est sûr que tout ce que je
recherchais je pensais que ça allait
m'apporter le bois mort mais c'est ça
m'épate validation encore dans l'autre
plutôt que intérieur celui qu'ont dû
penser la thérapie de penser la thérapie
qui a été moi même année j'étais tanné
de la tension juste que tu veux quand le
petit veulent avoir une petite amie ta
nea vente à des pressions un peu seul
mais j'aime encore non mais non mais
j'aime je veux dire j'aime ça parce que
maintenant je le sais que c'est un
milieu dans lequel mais oui mais si je
dis que j'ai fait me trône émis trois
saisons à cannes a dû vider raynaud on
ne fêtons ensemble le skull j'ai eu des
expériences qui comme acteur billet si
je le sais que je tape à deux places de
10 essais au final cette attention le
que je cherchais ma portée à réaliser qu
est ce un cas d'asthme à ce que le
mettons la tension puis le jeu encore
une fois que ruth mois sur le trône mais
c'est maintenant ma lecture de la
situation
la tension tom meighan et secondaires à
ta personne est secondaire ce que tu
fais dans vite c'est totalement parce
que tu es dans vie c'est pas dans le but
d'avoir d'attention mettons en ce moment
et peut-être ta job de renault au dessus
ces personnes ne voient solide c'est
pisser dessus puis à voir la tension
c'est comme secondaire tandis que mon
expérience personnelle de sortir de rudy
c'est qu'à voir la tension pis c'est la
chose principale que tu fais tu pilotes
le quand tu réalises qu'avant
d'attention c'est ce qui définit
souhaitent à leur maxi couche entraîne
le fond c'est ça ta pas sorti un album
de musique pour l'instant son nom tout
juste juste être une jeune fille dans
les voyages les membres issus et reviens
tard c'est au début j'ai eu le syndrome
de l'imposteur quand j'ai commencé à
faire mes émissions de télé parce qu'au
final je voudrais je ne m'attends à rien
juste des photos des frais thyroïde où
chaque année le débat je laisserais
farid ali fait ce qu'il veut non mais
moi mettons initialement juste un non
catégorique pour tout le monde mon
entourage sujet tellement victoroff le
genre puis c'est surtout la pression
comme des trop collée dessus tout un
discernement de terrain de comptes tu
deviens pas la personne que tu voulais
être puis tout le kit le tir
peut-être qu'en ce moment c'est moins
pire parce que là on s'est presque salle
est fort mais nous n'avons aucune des
cons à le sortir de là et que 130 mille
abonnés sur instruments typiques que le
salaire renseignements m puisqu'elle est
finalement talent est de faire du rock
et buntin m en 2000 pièces pour une
publication il va c'est donc le titre
acquis mais la joie faire cette
publication la place de de retourner
travailler puis crée des contes pour
enfants ce qui me faisait triper mais
comme travailler trois semaines pour le
savoir de rapala une publication
c'est ça fait que tu fais mal gré touati
fake mais là mais je mérite
qu'aujourd'hui et années que tout de
suit votre voie savoir qu'est ce qui va
se passer après t on le voit maintenant
là on voit qu est ce que les gens font
après et puis oui mais vivace a fait 6 y
aller j'irai pas pour le après mais si
je mentirais si je disais qu'un poème
dit pas moi qui ai genre qui quitte à
tirer exact pour l'expérience que ce
serait aussi piger dans le monde sont
ali créer un lien de vous un titre
unique d'avis qu'une est la face par
intense super charger dans un concentré
on vraiment concentré d'émotions
d'expérience pitié fac moi ça serait
plus dans cette optique là que j'irai
mais en même temps tu mets ton je
regarde d'ailleurs année je me dis j'ai
reçu un rapport le puits gens sauront
transmettons les jeux mobiles et mettez
les styles d'amour de ses postes créés
tandis bonne connexion pis si si
vraiment c'est le style de personnes tu
mets ton les filles peuvent pas je
trouverais
dans ma vie avec pas son dos mais si
c'est sûr que peut-être que le type de
candidats changé depuis
c'est une autre note à nice était restée
c'était leur commencement de odéon
savais pas trop ce sens c'est la façon
qu'ils ont présentés c'était vraiment
plus comme j'ai du temps mais c'était
plus heroes lost est moins maudit je
veux pas porter oui mais je peux passer
de critiques en aval le douchebag mais
c'était moins douchebag c'était moins
c'était moins bobo tout bien et me tiens
on était toute hâte cross systems et
pignons jeu c'était moins axé sur le
physique définitivement le triste
c'était beaucoup plus axé sur des gens
des personnalités je pense que quand on
fait un casting évidemment faux faut que
tu sois faut que ce soit attirant devant
un kodak le même temps mais je pense que
c'était beaucoup plus axé sur les
personnalités que sur un casting
physique maintenant moi c'est peut-être
ce qui a changé dès aujourd'hui d'un
métis imaginé deux dernières années
t'imagines si je me projetais l'hôpital
je sais pas si ce moment j'ai pas besoin
de rien changé lançant ce qui émet ou je
suis juste heureux que j'allais
bouleverser ce jeu c'est pour ça vaudra
à peine le fonds soit au président
faisait qu'il avait vécu un peu comme
moins certain mais le ce que tu dis ces
méthodes ce sera une expérience de plus
que tu recommandes rue moi je recommande
quand même parce qu'on n'en est sorti ce
serait tellement de positif est vraiment
plus big man is a là aucun pelouse juste
de pouvoir avoir vécu cette expérience
le spa tout le monde qui peuvent se dire
je sais qu'on change pas le monde mais
tu es quand même enfermé trois mois avec
des gens qui connaît pas ces d'autres
gens qui se voient pas qu'ils contrôlent
ta vie puis tu vis les mêmes émotions en
même temps que 12 autres personnes fait
qu'internet et aurait même temps que les
émotions de plus en plus je sais ça
c'est fou fait vite allemand des choses
que tu ne peux même pas expliquer fait
que je trouve que juste pour
l'expérience
la personne à limbe enfants est forte et
un bon entourage
je me dis non mal watts ce qui peut
arriver à la fin moi mon ex m'a sorti de
dégueulasse qu'est ce qui vient des gens
et leur fais moi j'ai pas nice puis je
me suis quand même bien seulement puis
passe quand même bien sûr titre effet
que je me dis qu'est-ce qui peut avoir
des supports fixes l'usagé de convenir
et carmen je trouve que les pignons de
taux était peu favorable était négative
négative mais des pas favorable du fait
qu stent est venu jeter en cours avec
holly est venu m'embrasse il rêverait de
jouer dans le doigt litres comprends-tu
majoré d affaires de 70 kg mais j'avais
peur mais je n'ai pas la dtcc
non mais je t'ai pas la détester mais je
n'ai pas pertinente c'est ça qui est des
flash pourquoi un certain ça a été la
perception que les gens ont eu ou ça
étonnant je m'en foutais j'avais peur
mais je pense que je pense que les gens
autour de total et les sikhs toi ok je
comprends sa famille ta famille j'allais
juste dire c'est ce qui a été dit suce
et la perception des gens mus et aussi
de retrouver un peu mais je me suis
questionné ni moins et on tue résenté
way s'est converti à manille ce que j'ai
dit ce que j'ai montré l'on dit non en
fait je les fais de lady s'est fait que
je me suis mis à me questionner aussi
affecter tout remets en question pitt a
besoin d'être justifiée berman et au
final tu as juste besoin de rien n'était
fait ta vie tu penses à autre chose mais
tous tués mais est-ce que tu vu de toi
mettons un terme à ce que tous les mois
mais je pense que c'était facile pour
moi parce que quand je le voyais moins
400 m a donné un bug ça a bougé depuis
dix sérieux steen tu viens [ __ ] la
manche mais c'est une méthode exprimer
mais moi quand je le vois à la télé je
sais comment ça s'est passé je ne
regarde que cela regarde sur le site est
intentions puis mes intentions jamais
été membres restants mais j'ose espérer
qu'ils n'ont jamais porte que
consciemment fait que je me regarde je
me dis ces machines qui le montrent pas
tout va comme twin six mois je me disais
mon nous devons comprendre que c'est
hendrycks mon meilleur ami qui me donne
des bucks à la bouche et et aide des
grand baie vous mesdames et messieurs ça
ne se pense pas comme ça dans les salons
du québec n'ont rien fait ici aussi ma
perception de mon groupe d'amis qui sont
au vert on voit pas la vie de la même
façon
je rentre avec des gens qui voient pas
nécessairement la vie comme moi avec une
vision intérêts que paie ford sur une
révision des gens dont on recherche
l'amour ou si les hôpitaux c'est
vraiment un sport moi j'essaie de
rentrer en disant moi je crois au couple
ouvert la monogamie c'est pas pour moi
puis mon meilleur ami mme french puis on
a sorti en salles en profite je n'avais
pas nécessairement toute l'opinion mais
pour l'heure tout period and été pour
revenir à ce qu'on parle est en touche
je ne dis pas c'est que quand j'ai
appelé la production pour proposer pezi
la première réponse de la production ça
a été si je prends poésie survient dans
le show that et si rien n'est fait il
fallait j'ai encore la passion
[Musique]
je suis vraiment etc puis je les assume
totalement puis maintenant je le fais de
la bonne façon mais j'aime son come back
à trancher sur cette personne c'est
exactement la somme qu'on fasse que je
saute d'un halo d'une caméra
[Rires]
j'y prenne djibrine pas été nimani sur
wii
non je fais un bisou au ph lui ont été
rendus
on a fait une longue parenthèse pour
arriver à la question est ce que les
péages de saison très fier de oye plage
de l'effet à de 16 ans il y aurait il
serait presque déçu mais j'ai le péage
de 30 ans soit lahoud est pas moi qui
vais demain non mais il serait déçu
parce que m
les pertes se doit et pas une opinion
favorable d'occupation double ce ces
sources
mais regardez ce qu'ils étaient non mais
il verrait où est ce que je suis
le ps est un vrai ce que ce chiffre est
gentil vegan
en faisant mes problèmes qui varient ou
est ce que comme un outil de ma vie et
placé en soit il serait fier mais il
serait sûrement genre il serait sûrement
surpris en tabarnak que j'avais fait
occupation double qui comprendrait pas
vraiment qu'est ce que c'est possible
parce que le ph à 16h20 16 ans tu
écoutes et en sont leurs débuts sont
leurs cinq points façon arcade avec ces
sources qui seraient ils seraient mêlés
comme un jeu tient sa longévité des wii
wii fit mais aussi georges commencé à
vraiment tripé sa littérature en l'air
quand gilles ujre le comte de monte
cristo ça a changé ma vie j'ai fait a
créé sur ses hôtes
et puis j'aimerais ça être un grand tort
le tir puis le haut des steppes roman
dernière chose que les grands auteurs
fais il a tellement parlé de foot je me
rappelle l'écrivain les livres que tu
avais labos qui sont ces journalistes
sean whitman a parlé avant m'est un peu
face au final véhicules extérieurs l'a
pas écrit moment une des scènes les plus
épiques de 2 mais agit point le sait
quand j'ai annoncé à ma directrice de
maîtrise que j'allais à occupation
double parce que je travaillais sur un
tueur s thomson que les auditions passé
plus de 15 ans qui est en train de
trahir mon mémoire de maîtrise en
littérature
un sujet tout à fait sérieux puis le les
options passer au dessus on passe plus
la première appert que je reçois de que
moi et ph et dans le fond tu es choisi
pour roder le choc et le g j'ai eu une
conversation vraiment du syli qui s'en
vient parce qu'en plus ma prof avait été
ultra facile tente avec moi pendant le
sport plus la maîtrise puis avait prêté
l'élève le plus le plus assidu jutier à
son travail dgt spa superfine défroqué
classement vote dans son bureau je sais
ta famille tes morceaux a aucune idée de
ce qui s'en vient
et je fais fait que dans le fond sa
fille bien que je sais pas comment le
dire autrement que je m'en vais à
occupation double déjà il juge la halle
éclate de réunit le genre était comme
jean parfait mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
un plomb se met à parler un peu d'entre
eux osent thomson ce qui faisait les
choses à faire après que tu vois là puis
après si tu pourrais écrire là dessus
maintenant c'est un peu ce que je
voulais faire sauf que l'idée c'est
quand je suis arrivée là dedans c'est
vous le savez c'est tellement genre les
émotions sont tellement vrai que tu es
président tu es trop proche de tout ce
qui ce passe le mythique coach caennais
mais nous quand elle est un temps pour
vraiment me même même si au final on
savait qu'on se concentre allait bien
puis que le pic st mais on était des
adversaires puis après ça jo ainsi qu'à
me faisait chier tu sais quand tu es
tellement de dakhla mais sa tête est en
train arrive sur puis le jamais j'avais
pas de prime n'y avait rien pour écrire
ces expériences le tipi
maintenant ça ne s'est pas avéré parce
que tu te fais trop prendre au jeu dans
le fond de toute façon c'est aujourd'hui
à écrire un livre sur cette expérience
le jeudi il ya personne qui perd il ait
à ces sorties cobra tice.com par lancôme
est en scène il parle d'aidé ou est ce
que c'est ça mais je disais c'est quand
même quelque chose qui existe c'est dès
la fin de la drug d'aller voir cette
course loterie mais tandis cours d'été
qui la tue le monde bon livre juste
comme il faut je le vis tous le
comprendre ou essayer de la comprendre
sur mon mais en même temps ça
m'intéresse comme pas de faire ce qu'on
veut faire comprendre au monde c'est
comme une expérience qui m'appartient
puis qui va rester pour toujours le
dessus fait que fait ben non c'est une
bonne conversation que j'avais fait
notre vie que de voir et elle expliqué
ceux ci avaient expliqué qu'ils avaient
d'abord c'est une belle entrevue bien
monter le style de voir le sillage du
cpie le sait
avec pitié que son projet de maîtrise
ted aller l'heure d'écrire là-dessus par
un peu du de l'infiltration du
journalisme un long article qui était
écrit la journaliste nous parlerons jobs
avait bien expliqué que c'était passé
pourquoi finalement je pense que j'avais
fait depuis cet été qui s'était passé
initialement que je m'étais inscrite lui
que tout ça c'était vraiment bien
vraiment bien explique-t-il
fils de toutes les nations tout repris
cet été comme ph quentin aux
infiltrations d'eau je pense que c'était
les oueds pq qui avait dit jah ph
campagne a tous pris pour des cons c'est
clos complet seulement les crocs quand
des gens ont lu seulement les lignes
city puis en même pas lu l'article de
mars qui en lui cédant voyons donc c'est
assez l'adil apprennent à l'anact a
perdu mes jambes bougent teller l'avant
puis je confirme que c'est ça le plan je
voulais genre excusé avoir perdu le team
lycée comme des quotes-parts excuse à
avoir perdu vous avez voté ces 14
personnes ont perdu deux règnes exacte
et gras qu'on est une belle tape de
perdre ses droits d'homme d'état de
fonds de 16 ans deux de 6 à 16 ans
secondaire 5
le shérif que j'allais arrêter la
natation qui est plus jouer un peu de
guitare chant et de la musique actuelle
voir là dedans dit oui je pense qu'ils
je pense que je serai définitivement pas
où est ce que j'aurai passé arrête de
surtout pop à des podcasts moi je t'ai
vraiment rien jeter plus être avertis si
j'étais plus jeune et s'est jetée pas un
grand communicateur puis bon je le suis
toujours paumé
[Applaudissements]
jamais pensé soi-même flotter tout à
fait du zèle me confesser de trois ans
n'a jamais pensé comprendre pourquoi
s'inquiéter
pourquoi je trouvais qu est ce qu on
aime ce qu'on cherche on le trouvera de
toute façon on va à la fois défaut faut
se laisser surprendre il faut reprendre
les chemins qui vous saisit les
opportunités qu'ils avaient aussi le
titre sens dans mon plan c'est
l'obsession puis moi j'ai tout le temps
été jetés à l'étude en musique jusqu'au
mali en ligne là dedans pour l'os et
j'ai jeté mon goal le tireur faisait du
matin au soir le dur rêver ou couché le
prince qu'elle pratiquait il y avait je
suis qui existe et je n'ai encore un
gros boost là dedans mais j'ai jamais eu
une espèce d'idée claire déjà c'est
exactement ce que je me dise où les
offert l'album où j'aurai ou moi je veux
composé la musique de film ou cheveux si
moi je veux susciter comme mais là en
général ces genres cette frappe d'en
face mais y en a il y en a vraiment qui
était bien c'est d'être hyper détails
qui vont utiliser en musique puis moi je
vois faire un album de métal d'hector
pour savoir qui les musiciens avec moi
peu importe avec qui le chanteur
oui il y en a moins jeunes partiront en
berne pourront faire se redresse éclat
et d'angoissé y est je t'avais enfin la
musique de film que je trais moi c'est
là dedans je sais ce que je dois faire
mais c'était comme bouger j'aime tout
fait comme un peu tout en même temps est
ce que tu faisais de la musique en même
temps une adaptation non mais je prenais
tu es dans le faux quand je te quitte
j'ai pris des cours de piano pendant
longtemps prince et au secondaire je
prenais des cours dès 14 heures le soir
victime et on j'arrivais chez nous après
avoir fait deux entraînements plus
pratiqué un peu métier je n'ai pas qu'il
y en a qui arrivent et concentration
musique pu quitter tôt leur vie mystique
au molard et de faire du sport pythie
comme auch jeu correct leur métier je
peux trouver dans game mais mais
aujourd'hui de ces mets ton café encore
aux essais chez la grand ville natale y
était et l hérault mal
non mais tu sais si tu jouis je jouais
col il s'agit de jouer avec ces
documents font mouche suite à risque
dans la vidéo que j'accompagne les
artistes avec qui tu étais le souffle à
la ga l'atelier amélie avec les minots
qui fait la voix on joue toutes les
semaines tous les dimanches ensemble le
jouet ou boudoir place ya les bienvenus
qu'ils ont vécu elle souffre au sol il y
en a qui ont que ceux qui ont connu le
ce qu'ils voulaient cette période le
tout les dimanches boudoir c'est autour
de 30 ans qu'avec les dimanches soirs au
boudoir et j'y allais j allais l'est et
comptant plus d'un tel comité s'étaient
jetés dans des mondes landes telbec qui
jouait les dimanches vos débuts vous
jetez pas la donne le type j allais tout
les dimanches vost et vf que j'ai tout
fait don bombe était restée dix jouer le
dimanche mais c'est le guitariste de
louge encore mr guitariste de patrice
michaud tu sais le bassiste lb bassiste
de karim ouellet est le drama rossi puis
la chanteuse était tellement bons amis
j'allais le voir le film et on j'avais
22 ans trop petit c'est tellement bon je
trouve ça mal appuyé prenez des cover
peut-il y lire faisait un peu à leur
manière oui j'aurais dit tous toucherait
ça m'a rassuré sans bon cd estimé le
soir et les ongles son smart pour toute
la gamme qui est elle aussi tout genre
les musiciennes québec sera montré les
dimanches dans le monde
c'est tout le monde qui ont pas des jobs
de ses gains c'était dimanche on se
voyait c'était vraiment le fun thiam a
mené ils m'ont demandé en aiguille je
commence à connaître au monde le coma
qui coûta maniement d elle elle quitte à
rire peut pas signer prochaine tu veux
tu faire le show du cluster pilotis
c'est con parce que ce texte ramène de
corée dans le fond mais non mais
l'événement les lots j'ai pratiqué toute
la semaine je précise parce qu'il est
tout neuf et s'est pris le chou et puis
là j'ai fait une bonne job ça y est
c'est l'fun pièce mon île pour pour papa
va être le prochainement factice
attentes
taklha mange comment marquer quinze
autres peluches et jouets étaient tous
les dimanches à 15 ou parent aujourd'hui
trois ans et s'est investie décolleté
gagne mais ouais ça pour dire que j'ai
fait ça par un beau être petit le jeu se
met à jouer des artistes qui font de la
compo de signer je travaille qu'une
fille s'appelle rien droit qui crée
c'est qui qui qui fait 6 tonnes ce qui
m'aurait bien on réalise ensemble 6
tonnes puis en fait studio ensemble et
c'est ce que je fais
saison je me souviens notamment son c-17
le tiges a fait ou 18 l'été au cégep
encore puis je faisais jouer avec m
ma blonde et l'époque il y en a qui est
chanteur ce type on a fait un espèce de
corpeau d'événements pour un groupe qui
fait comme un peu des conférences de
développement personnel unique et puis
le style on fait de la musique
l'ambiance était tout l'événement
s'était tu étais toi dans cinq ans
alé lô petit est la personne dans sa
musique mais c'est quand même posé la
question d'accès sauf à tout le monde
c'est notre prochain partait gagne faut
qu'on soit toujours attaquer la
prochaine soirée s'ils jouent comme un
môme chapeau mais si on pense ait dans
cinq ans je sais rien mémène pinatas une
bonne mais c'était vraiment ça tacle et
practice installé à écouter côté
objectifs de ceux qui luttent et est à
personne le sais pas moi qui mets grève
complètement et moi comme irréaliste
mais vraiment ambitieux sar est arrivé
paraît il allait lui arriver métier
finalement on va de fil en aiguille le
temps avance puisqu'il qui est peut-être
que ça sera pas exactement ce que je
pensais mais le processus je te dis tout
le temps était encore là dans un petit
bourg afin qu'il se penche vers et je
suis rendu j'ai peut-être acheté peau
chez paulo grosse carrière de l'univers
mais juste le fait de faire ce qui doit
rendre ce ppi ddd ndjoli procès speed
être bien là dedans je réformes à faire
j'aimerais qu'on soit une mini déception
non
la musique c'est comme et oui au oui/non
c'est cela j'ai fait un nom chez jadis
électorale monterrey dans vie en général
oui tu as l'air exige oui tout le monde
les autres attendent de lui jaurès est
si maintenant je sais bgc travailler ça
j'ai même nuit même par les difficiles
sur le t2 le sentiment ne jamais en
faire assez
depuis toujours j'ai définitivement fait
sûr mais tu vois c'est ainsi dans une
impasse parce que j'en fais vraiment
plus pete est satisfaits ou satisfaits
dans le fond je pense qu'ils aient par
un beau disque et étoffe secure je
voulais faire tout en plus mais en
réalité dans le concret je faisais pas
temps peut-être que j'étais paralysé par
ce temps cité lot puis finalement ça
faisait comme une loupe au pirée parce
que parce que c'est ce que je voulais
faire plus ce pilote est insatisfait de
tout mais ça faisait en sorte qu'ils
aient trier des foules de journée il est
arrivé lors des journées même pétrifié
par la tâche accomplie
ça discute tandis que le chiffrement
dans un bon beat que une bonne
discipline bonne routine de vie saine
petit ballon mais j'ai peur je t'ai pas
l'attrait du vaisseau temps qui s est
laissé aller sur deux afin de faire
cesser plus une structure moi j'ai
clairement besoin de structure va trop
depuis depuis que je mets ton gamin tu
te réveilles mettant de plus les
consignes mais c'est tout cas tu faisais
des shows des fois le vraiment d'ordre
et puis la force des mines parade parade
et animation par des années tim et en
cash à l'université quand j'étais au
cégep j'étais genre la machine de
discipline me tiens justement comme je
disais tantôt je t'ai jamais commis
pendant la buzelle au cégep
je prends ce qui a manqué à vos amis
qu'on commence j'ai ramé cours puis dès
que j'avais un break entre deux cours je
retourne dans mon lit cage pratique et
je restais jusqu'à 9h30 soir au cégep
tout les soirs je reprends la bulgarie
vers le coucher tu m'enlèves un genre
par tête c'était taker cpie pythie
j'avais peut-être prendre une bière
vendredi soir une photo d'un terme était
sinon c'était focus focus focus focus
mais j'étais bien là d'anti parce que
j'avais l'impression d'avancer j'ai
l'impression dé comme réaliser même aimé
concrétiser et puis j'étais drama
j'adorais ce ppi l'habitude d'enlever
adversité je construisais la musique
puis les bus mis à travailler c'est à
faire des shows beaucoup puis moins dans
le fond j'ai vraiment besoin d'une
structure pour commettre être organisé
pour tous ces pilotes
le fait d'aller faire un show à gatineau
un soir il l'a même âge qu'eux s'ils m'y
plais dans une chambre d'hôtel petite
couche à trois heures parce qu'ils te
filme concept à prix d'or après que tu
te relèves claude fait cinq heures de
route tu dois passer plus tu manges mcdo
puis le tout sera fait qu'à me
complètement pas rejeter au vélo des
tout le temps parce que moi j'ai comme
vraiment le j'ai vraiment le site défaut
d'en prendre trop de temps de me dire
oui à toutes les épices et la paiera
femme pour avoir l'impression dit rien
accomplir ceci étant fait tellement au
final mettant à trois fois fait que
l'impression de lire les asturies mon
frère tu en as fait 12 / / temps mes
enfants 4 exact oui c'est sûr que
j'étais tout le temps je te remercie
tout le temps d organiser plusieurs
perdez des baux de pilotes passent
j'en avais juste trop qu'il est la
pandémie gtg comme justement ça a
commenté le ménage complètement une [ __ ]
shoot
dès que j'ai recommencé à gagner un bien
qu'il ait tuées soit vraiment été si
2020 j'ai pris ce pas un peu plus haut
un peu plus relax mettant le mai 2021
j'ai comme dit telle gressard qu'on
finit petit j'ai fait acquis non le
genre je veux prendre le contrôle de mes
affaires à noter pileux je vais pas
mentir je me disais que je m'élève si je
me lève à 7 me un an avant
puis le fait que je me couche je me lève
tôt première chose que je fais je fais
deux en dictant fait que je m'élève fait
théorique tenter la chose dans ma vie
ticket mettons culte a voulu faire péter
kim que j'aime faire un fait que je fais
ce fait douze heures après celui
émettons 9h30 j'ai fait mes deux heures
le jeu des jeunes et plus je dois fermer
à la fin de la journée s'est jouée mais
pas un pape k6 si votre achat la part je
tousse femmes et enfants mais au moins
j'ai fait ici j'ai pas toute la journée
la culpabilité dente âge époque j'ai
pris qui d'entrée parce que des plus
cégeps c'est tout le temps là les plus
âgés c'est tout le temps le tir parce
que de la musique tu es la pratique de
son instrument mais ton petit peu tout à
fait plus rien et il peut toujours être
malade va devoir faire douze ans de
piano ou des carnets de notes à downing
street tandis que même le sport peut
couvrir 12 en allemagne à un bout de
temps dit que la musique c'est comme si
baugé véhicule vraiment longtemps avec
l'espèce de mac acheté au cégep je
prendrais tout le temps mais là chaque
seconde de ma vie que je t'ai pas dans
l'action de jouer mon instrument
je culpabilise tout le temps avec le
tatouage prennent cela mais c'est trop
répandue mais tu as vraiment mettre des
limites
ces mouches quelqu'un qui aime se la
disputent sur le travail mais à mes yeux
ça devient malsain mais parce que ça
devient difficile aussi car ton métier
c'est ta passion parce que quelqu'un il
faut juste pas en chine
art 8 à 5 arrive à mobiliser se pose pas
de questions oui ces soucis moi j'avais
un peu la main marquettois quand je fais
pas du design et je peux regarder des
revues j'ai gardé les yeux
des documentaires je me dis j'en ai pas
regardé aujourd'hui je me sens tellement
mais au final mais oui on a droit devait
se trouver il faut juste trouver
l'équilibré toutes ces sales les fêtes
le fait de faire ça en début de journée
après que les raids la journée je veux
dire oui tu l'as fait j'ai fait c'est
aujourd'hui le 6 octobre à faire de la
musique dans la journée si j'ai du temps
le soir mais au moins c'est comme ces
régles ipsa meutre puma le d'emporter
plus genre quelque chose que je fais
mais je pourrais être en train de faire
c'est pas si dans deux ans même s'ils
tentaient pas été quand même plus fin
qui est ajournée à culpabiliser mais oui
imposé deux ans même si c'est là ça
c'est la chose puis moi ccsa mettant
avec l'entraînement physique lucky qui
me ramène tout le temps pourquoi
maintenant à chaque jour je vais y aller
je pense que quand ça finit
ouais tu le regardes jamais jamais
jamais jamais n'y a personne qui ait
jamais regretté cette entrée une fois
jamais à bord sublet recensés mais il ya
personne qui est jamais sorti dans un
cadre si j'aurais pas dit non mais tu
peux quand même tandis que moi je me dis
c'est juste comme bonjean regrette pas
j'ai un bon sentiment mais c'est ça moi
je trouve ça la culpabilité de pas avoir
été c'est juste c'est selon mais cette
année si charge m je vois c'est possible
que je me dise qui est je me sens pas
bien
maintenant la culpabilité d'une journée
complète sans m'entraîner parce que je
suis tout le temps avec moi même que
personne qui m'impose de m'entraîner le
pij le fait vraiment juste pour moi je
le fais pas pour un désir de de former
ou de gagner un combat physique
d'attenté d'apparence le pas du tout
l'été puis juste le fait qu envers moi
même je pense tout le temps j'y vais
parce que chez quand ça va être fini
c'est sûr que s'il fallait pas laisser
ça je veux avant qu'on se laisse parce
que cette conversation achève entre que
sur micro mais avant qu'on se laisse je
veux qu'on fasse l'exercice inverse
ah oui j'allais déjà tard
dans cinq ans je laissais pas fini de
parler pour finalement akbas il m'a
donné tellement c'est ce qui me fascine
le plus maintenant dans notre relation
là on est tellement différent il loin
loin loin mais tellement pareil je ne
sais pas comment l'expliquer mettons le
je sais pas comment expliquer sur
exactement je pense si les petits gars
de les petits goodies inquiet pareil tu
comprends ce sens plus de dix ans qui
pareille paul l'homme qu'on est devenu
très vite parce que ça rien qui mette en
jeu move pas vraiment dans la vie met
toi la première fois que je t'ai vu la
première journée je te rendrai j'ai
parlé de ma vie comme si ça faisait
comme si on était désert sans aucun
tabou stand aucune retenue sans aucune
gêne aucune gêne mythique mais je sais
pas pour toi c'est un truc mais moi je
les sujets rapidement quand même
rapidement quand même qu'il y avait
comme une connexion qui était différente
qu'avec les autres que même si les
autres diocèses supports connectés
logiciel sûr et certain en terminant que
c'est parce qu'on sait pas parler
pendant un bout après audi - moi j'étais
sûr que tu m'aimais pas après oddo
betty le premier paix pour que tu
m'aimais pas mais si je veux dire il est
arrivé de sorte à faire je vous dit j'ai
quand même riche menti pendant trois
mois dans votre phase en vous disant que
joannie ce thème à blanc de traverser
seul flop je pense que je te l'avais dit
ado ado tu m'as jamais menti parce que
je me rappelle même rapidement qui je la
saison daudet loin pige pour les jeunes
du captalat les intéressent pour
peut-être ça les intéresse d'avoir les
dents de lait les décideurs des mais moi
je me rappelle même rapidement le jeu je
pense que c'est qu'un après votre nuit
de l'amour c'est george tiller un clip
de ce surdoué qui raconte la nuit le tir
puis je me rappelle qu' on a vu un
moment afghane
tu m'avais regarder lucidement petit
m'avait dit ph le jeu juste marre en
afrique puis tu m'avais dit ce qu à
partir de ce moment là tout ce que tu as
fait après de mensonges de quoi que ce
soit de vouloir nous sortirons nous
autres je n'ai jamais pris personnel ça
parce que tu m'avais du sud puis après
ça été tellement triste parce que tu
étais tellement offre aussi parce que je
tiens
mais quand on écoute les émissions en
plus sa fin le tout à mes poches que la
production avait avait démontré de ta
relation avec jesse sa valeur d'être
jose a dit me débecte n'était pas je
suis je te dis à la fin j'étais que je
déconne pas parce qu'on était pourtant
la dorna côte à côte puis on s'entendait
bien sûr tout mais à la fin moi je
pensais que c'était comme baba pitch
écoute il s'en câlisse de moins puisque
ben correct mais
mais c'est clark et on avait trop fort
kent by connector la vie fabienne
échanges 20 km jamais s'est jamais trop
tard d'affection seulement 5,1 dans
l'enceinte commencer vous avez commencé
on va vous laisser le monde l'a fait
dans 50 ou ph c'est tellement les bonnes
questions ces témoins
c'est une question qui n'est ce pas que
ça on espère très en verve constants y
compris moi je pense que dans le dernier
la dernière année j'ai eu une
trajectoire d'apprentissage personnel
puis de remise en question personnelle
qui est intéressante sur plein de
niveaux notamment au point de vue de
lego qui est la chose qui m'a sans que
je sache le plus nui dans ma vie puis
qui était aussi la chose qui fait que
j'étais aussi bon en natation mettons
c'était que j'étais derrière un bloc de
départ puis jeté les meilleurs puis
c'est une faute politique est possible
que quelqu'un de battre ici qui quand
même battait ça me faisait tellement mal
à l'égo que le retournement piscine le
lendemain pis que j'avais le feu d'en
face c'est ce qui m'a permis de me
rendre aujourd'hui sauf qu'une fois que
c'est fini les gosses sans vie de tous
les jours c'est un peu de la mare de
l'été puis dans ma dernière année c'est
un travail que j'ai commencé à accomplir
puis que je veux j'aimerais ça que dans
cinq ans j'avais ce travail là sont
rendus beaucoup plus loin que jamais
accepté plein d'affaires que kim qui me
heurte ou kim kim earth est un vin qui
me déplaisait ou qui me font me sentir
mal maintenant mais qui sont pas en lien
avec quelque chose que je contrôle n'ont
fait que j'aimerais ça être le seul
maître de mes émotions de mes sentiments
qui gêne c'est en fait dans sept ans je
sais pas où est ce que je vais à l'être
mais j'aimerais ça est rendu à un point
où est ce que je capable de laisser
tomber tout ce qui est pas sous mon
contrôle puis de continuer à faire ce
que j'aimais tant d'un point de vue plus
cartésienne de prolonger le messie
nation de dînette dans 5 h dans la même
situation exacte avec le studio puis
mettons le podcast en fait ce n'est lui
même pas fait c'est maintenant qu'on me
dit que dans cinq ans finalement j'ai
écouté j'ai lu en affaires dans un livre
dernièrement qui est qui me qui me fait
me glace tu es complètement si nani bana
tout ce que ça t'a fait ses classes et
peu importe qui tu arrives dans la vie
que tu sois coupable ou non tu es la
seule personne responsable de
commandites fils maintenant
moi ça me gêne sonore dernières années
ça a changé dans le dernier mot ça a
changé ma perception de la vie c'est
toujours tout qui décide comment t'y
fils il peut t'arriver de la fin
tragique d'avis que ce soit ta faute ou
pas tu peux perdre quelqu'un de proche
de ta vie d'une maladie comme tu peux y
perdre mon emploi où tu peux c'est une
amie tu la mettais la seule personne
responsable de com à thiviers de la
moins présente ça m'a amené à penser à
ses formes en somme ce look 1,5 ha tu
trouves vraiment la misère face je
vraiment d'interface sais pas ce que
c'est
c'est pas que l'abcès jamais t'éclate
donc mettons permettant quand on y va
plus en terme de points un endroit où
l'endroit professionnelle ou personnelle
mais vraiment une introspective à faire
sur moi c'est ça à l'intérieur de toi
maintenant sur le chemin sur lequel tu
es maintenant
bah ouais ou est-ce que tu aimerais que
tu amènes dans 50 non je comprends il
dit anand comprend oui trois questions
mais tu vois en ce moment géant des jeux
trouve ça va vous paraître vraiment de
la marde à 17 ans tu as dit mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est une belle
personne
non mais rien n'a changé en ce moment je
n'apprécie une personne ne fait
confiance à voir à la vie des cinq
prochaines années devrait dire pas de
gêne et de verser en plus dans la roma
non non ce
au niveau personnel ça va ça va quand
même bien quand même bien je sais moi
moi fait moins cinq ans et plus
l'horizon professionnel auquel je pense
que je demande domestique et qui la
continuité de faire ce petit jeu c'est
pas si ce ce qui se passe ici les
podcasts les conversations vont encore
eksi dans cinq ans peut-être que oui
peut-être que non je terminais mon vote
et qui sait peut-être que au contraire
ça va comprendre comment une grosse six
pieds deux grosses équipes qu'on va
arrêter le chapeau qui de québécois mais
messi bref on arrête de grossir ces
conversations non les avoir imprimées
non mais c'est sa mémé tu es sûr c'est
ce que j'aimerais ça continue plus
longtemps possible que des rencontres de
manger ce qu'on vienne je vive le
morceau toutes sortes de monde qui ont
la trentaine qui j'aimerais avoir
l'impression que si justement
aujourd'hui je suis comme crimes et ces
mets ton j'ai l'impression d'en
d'ailleurs deux années d'avoir fait du
chemin et péter comme des commandes
après si la personne que je suis mais
c'est parce que j'ai rencontré du monde
et l'autre qui fait qu'à chaque fois tu
apprends pittis à saas-fee réfléchisse à
traves ans et une introspection chaque
fois tu connais mieux en mieux puis tu
te rends compte des trucs à aussi à
laisser derrière ces comportements au dd
des idées des pensées et des opinions
est laissée derrière
enfin que faxer ce métier moi si ça ça
pouvait continuer grosse et puis tous
les projets satellites le au podcast au
studio puis en même temps en musique que
ça continue t moi j'aime bien gros
phares la réalisation des artistes ravi
leur travail leur direction artistique
l'arrangement des toons mixte ce moi
j'aime vraiment faire cette remarque
bruit dans cinq ans
non la duperie fred st-gelais titrait
singes même l'artiste fred st gelais
marie mais aussi ces frais sont gelés
qui est y mettons est le seul artiste
métal autre côté tu marie-mai manque
d'esprit assure marc st gelais et marque
sans appel puisque j'aimerais en faire
plus fakih miss je peux faire se
balancer ces deux villes eux également
que ça continue puisque ça marche je
joue est vraiment content on a autant 55
ans dans la même optique et ph penser
ici parce que professionnel honnêtement
j'ai aucune idée je vois et une mouche
si j'ai accepté dans la vie j'allais
prendre ce qu'à l'avenir ils s'arrêtent
au jour le jour mais j'ai avec tout mon
processus la dernière année je me suis
dit ce mot le moule à la thérapie m'a
permis de reprendre contrôle du vaisseau
mère que j'ai dans mon âme dans ma tête
c'est parce que ce que je viens une
émotion baptiste l anxiété leur grosse
le 6e puis je me perds là dedans comme
si j'avais pu le contrôle de ce qui se
passe c'est bien ce que je disais tantôt
de tour de contrôle de commande fils
fait que veut garder le contrôle de mon
dans cinq ans je me vois est encore un
contrôle de mon vaisseau moins d'être
pile c'est la seule chose honnêtement
parce que c'est là c'est la pire affaire
qui met qui m'arrivait cg véhicules ap
rafah qui pouvait m'arriver déraisonnée
d'en perdre complètement ce contrôle le
pida de l'avoir retrouvé ce que je
croyais possible même si je sais que
j'ai une réflexion avec et avec jo il ya
une coupe des coupes de moi
deux multi on peut se rendre malade a
été très serré mais qui sont peu se
rendre malade a été dressée on peut
toujours se guérir avec notre peuple
comme --et non mais je vous dis je
je pense qu'on a le contrôle de bain des
affaires avec notre cerveau qu'on sait
pour 1000 jours attitude est positive
d'être toujours été c'est son nom mes
désirs des démonstrations ses sautes ici
on peut y avoir des maladresses on peut
pas nier un cancer sont peu regardants
santé puissent garder mieux puisse
garder plus ce soir que ça l'est c'est
un impact global mais j'imagine que ça
se fait quel est le sens où si je pense
que je pense prend soin de ton corps ton
esprit vaut mieux encore c'est ça qui me
fait vraiment axé sur ce je me vois dans
cinq ans je veux garder le contrôle de
mauvais souvenirs très forts pezi pour
conclure cette instance
ok je pense je suis certaine que j'ai
juste envie d'être
où est ce que je dois à être convertis
si j'ai trop facile sinon mais c'est
parce que c'est un même thème et en
littérature on m'apprenait souvent que
les clichés de le bruyant parce que oui
mais celle ci reste que je veux vouloir
avant 6 h 50 il m'avait posé cette
question là je te jure que c'est parce
que je leur ai répondu que j'aurais eu
tort sur toute la ligne
parce que le fumier ou est-ce que je
suis fait que ça se peut que dans cinq
ans ma vie est totalement à l'envers où
qu'elle soit pareil mais j'espère juste
être bien avec ce que je suis en train
de vivre tout comprendre tout ce que je
veux que ce soit une continuité ou
l'opposé j'espère je sais ta bonne place
peapod dans cinq ans m'a regardé puis me
dire écrit ce type hésita pas fait de
chemin était pas bonne place était
poreuse qui attendent d'être tout sens
comme une inconnue dans ta propre vie tu
comprends tu j'ai juste envie d'être
où est ce que je dois beaucoup
d'objectifs clairs le dans 5 ans jouer
tout non parce que ma vie est tellement
tient à gauche puis à droite on dirait
c'est pour ça c'est des fois je l'aimais
avoir des priorités puis ce genre
d'affaires le parce que je donne dans ce
sens que je vais au jour le jour
puis je les accepte vraiment bien je le
vis vraiment bien puis je comprends pour
les personnes extérieures dont j'aime ça
peut être difficile à suivre
mais je me suis perdu dans ma tête tout
ça pour utiliser ce métier en bout de
ligne je dois faire déferler dans cinq
ans ça peut être le fun mais tel but
c'est d'être bien
c'est un python pipe le maintien est en
bonne position pour mais c'est vrai
aussi dans ce cas j'aimerais savoir mon
garage avec les outils tout multiple à
ce triple monte à matmata pour
travailler parce que je veux me prennent
aujourd'hui si vous saviez à quel point
j'ai envie de pipi dont tout s'est joué
à l'eau